السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
يطيبوا لنا نرحب بكم في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه بمناسبه عقد القمه العربيه
الصينيه الاولى الهادفه لرفع مستوى
التعاون المشترك بين الدول الاعضاء
بالجامعه الدول العربيه وجمهوريه الصين
الشعبيه بما يقضي المصالح المشتركه لدولنا
كما يسرنا ننقل لكم تحيات سيدي خادم
الحرمين الشريفين الملك سلمان بن عبد
العزيز ال سعود حفظه الله
وتمنياتنا بنجاح اعمال هذه القمه اصحاب
الجلاله والفخامه والصمول
انها علاقه تاريخيه بين الدول العربيه
وجمهوريه الصين الشعبيه قائمه على
الاحترام وتبادل والصداقه والتعاون في
العديد والمجالات
الاهميه القصوى لدعم مسيره تطور والتنميه
من اجل تطوير اقتصادياتها شعوبها
وننظر في المنطقه العربيه ببالغ الاهتمام
بما يحقق جمهوريه الصين الشعبيه من نمو
الطرد وتقدم تقني متسارع جعلها ضمن
اقتصاديات الرائده عالميا ويؤسس العقاد
هذه القمه لمرحله جديده للارتقاء للعلاقه
بين دولنا وتعزيز الشراكه في مجالات لا
تهتم المشترك ومن اجل تحقيق المستقبل
تطمحلال شعوبنا وتنعم الاجيال القادمه
بالرخاء المنشود علينا بواسطه تحديد
التعاون في المجالات التجاريه واستثماريه
والماليه بين الدول العربيه والصين
في اطارات ثنائي والمتعدد وتطوير تنسيق
السياسي على ساحه الدوليه تجاه القضايا
الاقليميه والدوليه ذات احتمال المشترك
اصحاب الجلاله والفخامه والسمومه والمعالي
تعمل المملكه على تحديد التعاون الدولي
لمواجهه التحديات التي تواجهها عالمنا
ودعم العمل الدوري المتحدد الاطراف في طلب
مبادل الامم المتحده بممارسه بتحقيق
مستقبل واحد الشعوب الاجيال القادمه ان
لمده يكون لحجم الاتحاد الذي مثل التغيير
المناخيمه ايجاد حلول اكثر اصتدامه
وشموليه في اطار نهر متوازن وسعيده اثار
سلبيه مع المحافظه على مستويات نمو
الاقتصاد العالمي حيث نستهدف الوصول
الحياه الكربون دون تاثير على النمو
والسلاسل الامداد وتفهم المملكه تعاون
وشاركاتها الدوليه مع الدول العربيه
والصين في اطار الشرق الاوسط الاخضر ونؤكد
الاستعداد التفاعل الايجابي مع المبادرات
التي تعزز عملنا البيئي المشترك مع مراعات
المصالح التنمويه الدول وتفاوته امكانيات
بينها وفضل تنامي يحدد التحديات الدوليه
الاخرى من ذلك الامن الغذائي ومن الطاقه
تاتي اهميه الت معي مبادرات الجاده
السائله تنشيط وصرت التعاون والعمل
الجماعي ونثمن دور الجمهوريه تصير الشعبيه
بطرح عدد المبادرات القيمه ومن اهمها
وزاره اصدقاء التنميه العالميه التي
تتوافق مع الجوانب عديده معنويات المملكه
تجاه دعم التنميه المستدامه وتحديد الامن
الغذائي اصحاب الجلاله والفخامه والسمو
المعالي تتطلب التنميه الاقليميه
والدوليهود
بيئيه وسياسيه واجتماعيه مستقره وامنه
وتكثيف جهود المجتمع الدولي لمعالج
القضايا الاقليميه الدوليه
وتستمر المملكه جميع الجهود لتعزيز الامن
والاستقرار في المنطقه وتدعم الحلول
السياسيه والحوار لحل النزاعات الاقليميه
والدوليه وتؤكد ضروره وجود عادل ودائم
القضيه الفلسطينيه
وفقرات الشرعيه الدوليه ومضادات السلام
العربيه بما يقفل للشعب الفلسطيني حقه في
اقامه دولته المستقله على حدوثه 67
وعاصمتها القدس الشرقيه نقدر موقف الصين
الداعم للحمل دولتين مبادره السلام
العربيه
كما تدعم المملكه الجهود الرامي الوصول حل
سياسه شامل لليمن لانهاء الازمه اليمنيه
وفق المرجعيات الثلاث ونشيد بدعم جمهوريه
الصين الشعبيه والمبادرات السعوديه تجاه
اليمن كما تؤكد المملكه اهميه مضاعفه
الجهود الرامي لجد حلول سياسيه لانهاء
الازمه في كل من سوريا وليبيا بما يكن
تحقيق الامن والاستقرار والازدهار في
البلدين الشقيقين
دائره العمل العربي المشترك
وفي الختام نجدد تاكيد اهميه مواصل
التعاون العربي الصيني بما يخدم اهدافنا
المشتركه تطلعات شعوبنا والقيام بدوره
وفعاله على الساحه الدوليه وان تساهم
نتائج هذه القمه في تحقيق اثاره ايجابيه
مستعده في جميع المجالات على المستوى
الاقليمي والدولي مقدلي الامين العام
جامعه الدول العربيه والمسلمين امانه ما
يبذرون من جهود موفقه في هذا الايطار شكرا
[تصفيق]
والان ادعوا فخامه الرئيسيه جمهوريه الصين
الشعبيه لالقاء كلمه فليتفضل
اصدقاء اهلا وسهلا بكم
اشكرك على الجانب السعودي على ما قام به
من الحفاوه ضيافه وترتيبات دقيقه
ويساعدني ان اجتمع ما حضرت الزملاء تحت
سقف واحد
لعقد القيمه الصينيه العربيه الاولى
ان هذه القيمه
حدث مفصلي في تاريخ العلاقات الصينيه
العربيه
وتقود
ستقوت العلاقات وتعاون بين الصين ودول
العربيه
بجذورها في اعماق التاريخ حيث
السراء والضراء في التيار
الوطني
وحققت تتهاون والكاسب المشترك تيار
العولمه الاقتصاديه
تتماسك في الحق والعداله في العالم
المتغير ولا المتقلب وبلورت من خلالها روح
صداقه الصينيه العربيه المتماثل في
التضامن وتازر والمساواه ولمن فعل متبادله
والشمول والاستفاده المتبادله
يعتبر تضامن
لصداقه الصين العربيه
حيث نتبادل دعم ثابت في لقاء ضايع متعلقه
بالمصالح على حيويه للجانب الاخر
ونتحد ونتقدم معا في قضيه تحقيق احلام
نهضه الامه
الفريق الواحد في المعركه ضد جاي حدا
فيروس
الشراكه الاستراتيجيه الصينيه الاعرابيه
القائمه على التعاون الشامل والتمير
مشتركه للمستقبل الافضل قويه لا تنقطع
تعتبر المساواه ولما فعل متبادله قوى دافع
لا تنبض لصدقه الصينيه العربيه يحدث تعاون
الصين العربي
الصيني العربي
المتبادل بين الجانبين
27 مليار دولار امريكي
وتنفيذ اكثر من 200 مشروع في اطارتها في
بناء الحزام وطريق التي عادت بلا خير
على قرابه
الصينيه العربيه
تتبادل الحضرتين الصينيه العربيه اليه
اعجاب
وتسجلان فصولا تاريخيا رائعه من التعلم
المتبادل والاستفاده المتبادله
نستلهم بلا حكمه من الحضاره العريقه
للجانب الاخر
الحقيقيه للحضاره على وهو لاهتمام بالسلام
ودعوه الى الانسجام والجزم بالتعهدات
والسعي وراء الحق
مدافع عن الاصاله
على الصراع على حضرات
وندعوا سويا الى الحوار بين الحضارات
ونلاحظ التمييز الحضاري
ونحافظ على تنوع الحضاري في العالم
منطقه شرق الاوسط تغيرات جديده وعميقه
باتت رغبه الشعوب العربيه في السلام
والتنميه اكثر الى حاحا
واشتات نداءاتها الداعيه الى الانصاف
والعداله
في هذا السياق على الجانبين الصيني
والعربي
بين الصين والدول العربيه
بما يعود بمزيد من الفوائد على الشعوب
الجانبين ويساهم في قضيه تقدمي للبشريه
و120
بالاستقلاليه والسيالات المصالحه المشتركه
يدعم الجانب الصيني جهود الدول العربيه
لاستكشاف طرق التماويه التي تتماشى مع
ظروفها الوطنيه
وتحكم في مستقبلها ومصيرها في ايدها
ويحرس الجانب الصيني على التحميق الثقه
لتراتيجيه المتبادل مع الجانب العربي
وتبادل الدعم الثابت في ما ساعي الجانب
الاخر الى الحفاظ على سياده البلاد
والسلامه الاراضي ولا الكرامه الوطنيه
وعلى الجانبين تماسك سويا بمبدا عدم تدخل
في شؤون الداخليه
المشروع على الدول الناميه
و120
على التنميه الاقتصاديه وتعزيز تعاون
القائمه على الكسب الى المشترك من ضروري
تعزيز الموعمه بين استراتيجيات التمويه
وبناء الحزام وطريق بجوده عاليه
ومن ضروري تطويد تعاون تقليدي في مجالات
الاقتصاد وتجاره وطاقه والبوميه تحتيه
وغيرها
وتقويه الخطاب النمو المساعده مثل
التاميره
وفتح افاق جديده في مجالات الطيران
والفضاء والاقتصاد الرقمي والاستخدامات
السلميه
لطاقه النوويه
مع تحديات الكبرى القائمه مثل امن الغذاء
وطاقه
مع جانب العربي على تنفيذ مباره
جميعا
على السلامه
يدعم الجانب الصيني الجانب العربي في
ايجاد حلول
السياسيه للقضايا الساخنه والشائكه بلا
حكمه العربيه
ونحو المجتمع الدولي
على اي احترام الشعوب شرق الاوسط
باعتبارها
السياده
طاقه ايجابيه تخدم الامن والاستقرار في
الشرق الاوسط
ويرحب الجانب الصيني
في تعزيز السلام والامانه في الشرق الاوسط
علينا تعزيز تبادل الحضاري وزياده التفاهم
والثقه المتبادله
من ضروري توسيع نطاق تبادل الافراد
وتعميق تعاون الانساني وثقافي وتبادل
الخبرات في الحكمه والاداره
ومن ضروره رفض
الاسلام فوبيا
بشكل مشترك
واجراه تعاون في نزعه التطرف
ورفع ربط الارهاب
بيعرق او دين بعينها
ومن ضروري تكريس قيم البشريه المشتركه
المتمثله في السلام والتاميه والانصاف
والعداله والديمقراطيه والحريه
والنصب قدوه للتواصل والاستفاده المتبادله
بين الحضارات في العصر الجديد
راينا بارتياح
انه تم الاتفاق في هذه القمه على العمل
بكل جهود على بناء المجتمع الصيني العربي
للمستقبل المشترك نحو العاشر الجديد
مع وضع الخطوط العريضه لخطه تعاون شامل
بين الصين
تطور العلاقات الصينيه العربيه
على تنفيذ الاعمال الثمانيه المشتركه
خلال السنوات الثلاثه الى الخمسه القادمه
التي تغطي المجالات الثمانيه التاليه
تدعيم التاميا الامن الغذائي الصحه
التنميه الخضراء والابتكار امن طاقه
الحوار بين الحضارات
تاهيل الشباب
الامن والاستقرار
قد افاده الجانب الصيني الجانب العربي
بالمحتويات المفصله للاعمال الثمانيه على
المشتركه
وسيعمل مع الجانب العربي سويا على تنفيذها
في اسرع وقت ممكن تحقيقه حصاد مبكر
ايها الزملاء ولا اصدقاء
انا القضيه الفلسطينيه
تحوم السلام والاستقرار في الشرق الاوسط
وتدعى الضمير الاخلاقي
للبشريه على المحك
لا يمكن ان يستمر الظلم التاريخي الذي
يعاني منه شعب الفلسطيني الى اجل غير مسمه
ولا تجوز المساومه على حقوق الوطنيه
والتماسك بمبدا الاراضي مقابل السلام
والزيادات المساعدات الانسانيه والانائيه
لفلسطين
للدفع الحل العادل والعدل للقضيه على
الفلسطينيه
[موسيقى]
نرحب الجانب الصيني بتقدم المهم الاخير
الذي حققته جهود على ويستات العربيه للدفع
المصالح الداخليه للفلسطينيه
الورد
المستقله ذات الصياد الكامله على حدود 77
وحسمتها القدس الشرقيه
ويدعم النيل فلسطين على عدويه الكامله في
الامم المتحده
وسيواصل تقديم المساعدات الانسانيه الى
الجانب الفلسطيني
لدعمه لتنفيذ
المشاريع المعيشيه
كما سيزيت من التبرعات الى وكاله الامم
المتحده لاغاثه وتشغيل اللاجئين
الفلسطينيين في شرق الادنى
كويت الزملاء اصدقاء
على المؤتمر الوطني العشرين بالنجاح
حيث تم تحديث
المهام والطرق
العظيمه للامه الصينيه على نحو شامل من
خلال التحديث الصيني
سيلتزم الصين
بالحفاظ على السلامه في العالم وتعزيز
ضمير مشتركه ودافع ببناء مجتمع المستقبل
المشترك للبشريه
وسيلتزم بكل ثبات في السياسه خارجيه سلميه
مستقله والدفاع عن العداله والانصاف دورين
في بناء على حزام وطريق بجوده عاليه
بما يوفر فرصنا جديده
لكافه الدول بما فيها الدول العربيه من
خلال التنميه الجديده في الصين
اي زملاء
المحترمون والاصدقاء
ان القضيه العظيمه تبدا بالحلم
وكنجز بالعمل الملموس
روح الصداقه
للعلاقات الصينيه العربيه شكرا لكم
[تصفيق]
الرئيسي على كلمته والانا ادعوا دوله
السيد ايمن عبد الرحمن وزير الاول في
الجمهوريه الجزائريه الديمقراطيه الشعبيه
لقاء كلمه فريده يتفضل
شكرا بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم والصلاه
والسلام على اشرف المرسلين صاحب السمو
الملكي الامير محمد بن سلمان بن عبد
العزيز ال سعود ولي العهد ورئيس مجلس
الوزراء فخامه الرئيس
جمهوريه الصين الشعبيه اصحاب الجلاله
الامين العام لجامعه الدول العربيه
السيدات انه لما من دواعي السرور ان نجتمع
اليوم في مدينه الرياض
بهذه المناسبه ان اتقدم بجزيره الشكر الى
حضره خادم الحرمين الشريفين الملك سلمان
بن عبد العزيز ال سعود وولي عهده صاحب
السمو الملكي الامير محمد بن سلمان بن عبد
العزيز والشعب السعودي الشقيق على كرم
الضيافه التي حضينا بها منذ وصلنا الى هذا
البلد الكريم
رئيس الجمهوريه السيد عبد المجيد الرئيس
الحالي لمجلس جامعه الدول العربيه على
مستوى القمه الذي يتابع باهتمام خاص اشغال
قمه هذه ويتمنى لها كل النجاح باعتبارها
خطوه شديده في مسار بنا شارك استراتيجيه
بين الصين والدول العربيه مبنيه على اسس
الاحترام المتبادل والتعاون المثمر والنمو
المشترك اصحاب الجلاله والفخامه والسموم
والمعاني ان اجتماعنا اليوم يحملنا على
استذكار التواصل بين حضرتين العربيه
والصين الضاربه الجذورها في اعماق التاريخ
حيث ارتبط الجانبان بعلاقات امتدت على مدى
اكثر من الفي سنه عبر طريق الحرير برا
وبحرا وكان السلام والانفتاح والتسامح
والتعاون سمه بارزه للتواصل بين الجانبين
ويشهد تاريخنا المعاصر بدوره على استمرار
هذا الدرس التاريخي المتميز من خلال عديد
محطات التعاون والتضامن بين الطرفين اذ لم
تتردد الصين في دعم القضيه الفلسطينيه
ومسانده حركات التحرر في الدول العربيه
وبدورها لم تتخلف الدول العربيه في دعم
مبدا الصين الواحده واستعاده مقعدها
الشرعي في الامم المتحده ولذا ياتي
اجتماعنا اليوم في موعد متجدد مع التاريخ
لنواصل تعميق التعاون بين الجانبين والذي
عرف خلال السنوات الاخيره قفزه نوعيه بلغت
معها معدلات التبادل التجاري والاستثمارات
البينيه مستويات قياسيه جعلت من الصين
الشريك التجاري الاول للدول العربيه التي
اصبحت بدورها سابعه شريكان
الاول من النفط الخام
وقد انتقلت هذه الشراكه الى مرحله جديده
عبر تاسيس منتدى التعاون العربي الصيني
سنه 2004 كايطار شامل للتعاون الجماعي
مدعوم باليات سياسيه واقتصاديه واجتماعيه
ثلاثه المبادره الصينيه الحزام والطريق
الذي التي تؤكد دعمنا لها الاحتمادها على
برامج انمائيه في مجالات مجالات البناء
التحتيه الاساسيه والاتصالات والطاقه وهو
ما من شانه خلق طرابط وتشابك بين
اقتصاداتنا وانسيابيه اكثر
لمبادالاتنا التجاريه وفضاءا ارحب
الاستثمارات الى المشتركه كما لا يفتون ان
اشيد بالدعم الذي الذي قدمته الصين للدول
العربيه لمكافحه جائحه كورونا في نموذج
تضامن لا تنفصل فيه الابعاد الانسانيه عن
العلاقات الاقتصاديه والتجاريه اصحاب
الجلاله والفخامه والسمو والمعاني وهذا
صعيدي ثنائي ترتبط الجزائر والصين بعلاقات
تاريخيه واستراتيجيه تمتد الى ثوره
التحرير الجزائريه حيث كانت الصين اول
دوله غير عربيه تعترف بالحكومه المؤقته
سنه 58 كما يتقاسم البلدان وجوهات النظر
ازاء العديد من القضايا ذات الاهتمام
المشترك ويتبدلان الدعم الثابت حول
المسائل التي تخص المصالح الجوهريه
والاهتمامات الكبرى لكل منهما وقد تكللها
مسار التعاون بين البلدين بتوقيعه على
الاعلان القاضي باقامه علاقات شراكه
استراتيجيه شامله سنه 14 كما اعتمدها
الخطه الخماسيه الثانيه لشراكه
الاستراتيجيه الشامله 22 26 كما تم
التلقيحيها ايام قبل انعقاد قمهتنا
المباركه هذه على الخطه التنفيذيه للبناء
المشترك للمبادره الحزام والطريق التي
انضمت اليها الجزائر سنه 18 والخطه
الثلاثيه 22 24 التعاون في مجالات الهامه
وهو بقى يعكس الرغبه المشترك الجزائري
والصين في خدمه تعزيز التعاون الشامل
والمثمر بين العالم العربي وجمهوريه الصين
الشعبي اصحاب الجلاله والفخامه والسمو
والمعالي في ظل حاله الاستقطاب التي
يعيشها النظام الدولي فان تعزيز العلاقات
الاستراتيجيه بين العالم العربي والصين من
شانه ان يسهم في بروز عالم متعدد الاقطاب
بعيدا عن السياسات الاحاديه ومساعي
الهيمنه وهنا اود ان اشيد بموقفنا المشترك
تجاه القضيه الفلسطينيه التي تمثل القضيه
المركزيه في العالم العربي بما يستوجب
تكثيف جهود الجانبين ايجاد حل عادل وشامل
ودائما لها وقد بادر رئيس الجمهوريه السيد
عبد المجيد التبون خلال القمه العربيه
التي احتضنتها الجزائر في غره نوفمبرت
والتي كانت عن حق قمه لما الشمل باقتراح
انشاء لجنه اتصالات وتنسيق عربيه من اجل
دعم القضيه الفلسطينيه
للمطالبه بعقد جمعيه عامه استثنائيه بمنح
دوله فلسطين العضويه الكامله في امم
المتحده وندعوا الصين من هذا المنبر
الانخراطي في هذا المسعى ودعم الموقف
العربي وفي ختامي هذه الكلمه اود ان اجدد
الشكر للمملكه العربيه السعوديه قياده
وشعبا امنا ان يتحقق لنا من هذه القمه ما
نصب اليه من تعزيز وتطوير لتعاونها خدمه
لاهداف السلم والامن والتنميه وتحقيقا لما
تصبوا اليه شعوبنا في مزيد من التقدم
والرفاه وانما واذا اتمنى لاعمال هذه
الدوره التوفيق والنجاح اشكرك على حسن
الاسراء والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله تعالى
وبركاته
[تصفيق]
اشكر دوله السيده ايمان عبد الرحمن على
كلماته والان ادعوا معالي السيد احمد ابو
الغيط الامين العام لجامعه الدول العربيه
للقاء كلمتين تفضل
صاحب السمو الملكي الامير محمد بن سلمان
ال سعود ولي عهد المملكه العربيه المتحده
ال ال ال ال المملكه العربيه السعوديه
رئيس مجلس الوزراء
فخامه الرئيس
جمهوريه الصين الشعبيه اصحاب الجلاله
والفخامه والسموحه واصحاب المعالي
والسعاده السيدات والساده يطيبوا لي في
المستهلك كلماتها تقدم بخالص الامتنان
والتقدير الى خادم الحرمين الشريفين جلاله
الملك سلمان بن عبد العزيز ال سعود واليكم
صاحب السمو الملكي الامير محمد بن سلمان
ال سعود ولي العهد رئيس مجلس الوزراء على
حسن الوفاه الوفاه وكرام الضيافه وكل
الشكر للمملكه العربيه السعوديه على توفير
كافه الامكانيات الكفيله بانجاح هذه القمه
الاولى من نوعها والشكر موصول كذلك الى
جمهوريه الصين الشعبيه الصديقه على ما
توجيه من اهتماما وحرص على انجاح التعاون
العربيه الصينيه ان انا انعقاد اول قمه
عربيه صينيه يعكس المستوى الرفيع الذي
بلغته علاقات الشراكه الاستراتيجيه بين
الجانبين كما يعد تتويجا ان المسار طويلا
من النجاح الذي حققه منتدى التعاون العربي
الصينيه منذ تاسيس عام 2004 في القاهره
لقد حظيت العلاقات العربيه الصينيه خلال
العقدين الماضين باهميه خاصه ضمن اجنده
الدبلوماسيه العربيه الجماعيه وصار
الارتقاء بالعلاقات احد البنود التي تعرض
تعرض باستمرار على جدول اعمال مجلس جامعه
الدول العربيه كما يؤكد المجلس دوما على
حرص الدول العربيه على تعزيز تلك العلاقات
مع الصين في مختلف المجالات صحيح ان الدول
العربيه تتمتع فرادى بافضل العلاقات مع
الصين الا ان الجهاد المبذول لتطوير
العلاقات بشكل جماعين كما نفعل اليوم من
خلال هذه القمه ياخذ العلاقات بين
الجانبين الى مستوى ابعد واعمق ان الصين
تعد اليوم الشريك التجاري الاكبر للعالم
العربي ولا تتصر العلاقات بين الجانبين
على الاقتصاد والتجاره بل هي تقف على
قاعده صلبه من راقصه ثقافي والانسان بين
نظامين حضاريين يضرب كل منهما بجذوره في
اعماق التاريخ ولد كل منهما اعتزاز كبير
بهذا العنق الثقافي والحضاري الممتد في
الزمن والمستمر في العصر الحاضر كما لدى
كلا منهما الرغبه الاكيده في مد جسور
التعاون
على كافه المستويات الانسانيه والثقافيه
والعلميه والاكاديميه وعلى التعاون وتبادل
الدعم
والمسانده لمواجهه جائهه كافه 19 يعد
نموذجا متميزا لمتانيه العلاقات بين
الجانبين اصحصت كل من الصين والدول
العربيه على تبادل الخبرات والتجازات
الطبيه الامر الذي ترك اثرا طيبا في نفوس
الشعبين العربي والصيني وسامه في التخفيف
من اثار الجائحه ان العلاقات العربيه
الصينيه تقف على ارضيه صلبه من المبادئ
المشتركه وهنا فاننا نقدر عليها دعم الصين
المستمر لحقوق الشعب الفلسطيني غير
القابله للتصرف وفي مقدمتها حقه المشروع
في اقامه دولته المستقله على خطوط الرابع
من يونيو 67 وعاصمتها القدس الشرقيه ان
الوضع في الاراضي الفلسطينيه المحتله غير
قابل الاستمرار في ظل غياب اي افق لتسويه
سياسيه على اساس حل للدول بما ينظر
بانفجار خطير لن يكون في مصلحه الاستقرار
في الشرق الاوسط
ونتطلع لقيام الصين الصديقه بكل تاثيرها
على الساحه الدوليه بالدفع في اتجاه اطلاق
عمليه سلميه ذات مصداقيه تقود الى انهاء
هذا الاحتلال الذي طال عمده كما نتطلع الى
دعم المسعى الفلسطيني للحصول على ادويه
كامله في الامم المتحده وفي هذا السياق
اشير ايضا الى موضوعان ينتهي ينطويان على
اهميه خاصه الاول هو ظاهره التغير المناخي
والتي تقتضي مواجهتها طاقه ثم عادلا
للاعباء ومعادله منصفه للانتقال الى نظام
اقتصاديا اقل ضررا بالبيئه واقل تسببا في
الانبعاثات من دون الاجحاب بحقوق الدول
الناميه في النمو وبنظره بعيده المدى
وتدريجيه للتحول في مصادر الطاقه لا يكون
من شانها زعزعه الاقتصاد العالمي اما
الموضوع الاخر فيتعلق بحذر انتشار النووي
وهو امر ينطوي على اهميه بالغه لمنطقتنا
عربيه في ضوء سعي ايران الحثيث لامتلاك
التقنيه المستخدمه للتسليح النووي مع
اصرارها على عدم اخضاع منشاتها النوويه
للتفتيش وكذا في ضوء رفض اسرائيل للانضمام
الى معاهده عدم الانتشار الاسلحه النوويه
اصحاب الجلاله والفخامه والسموم ان توثيق
التعاون العربي الصيني يمكن ان يطلق طاقات
هائله وفرصا بلا حدود خاصه لقطاع الشباب
فبامكانيات التنميه في المنطقه العربيه دي
كبيره وواعده والخطط التنمويه الطموحه
يمكن ان تغير وجه المستقبل ولافه ولا
تفوتني في هذا المقام الاشاره والاشاده
بالمبادرات الرائده التي طرحها فخامه
الرئيس الصيني جيمنج وبالاخص كل من مبادره
الحزام والطريق ومبادره التنميه العالميه
واللتين تشكلان فرصه هامه لتعزيز عواصر
التعاون بين الدول الناميه ورفع حجم
الاستثمارات في مجالات التنمويه وحيويه
واحده في ختام كلماته تقدمه مجددا بخلص
الشكر والتقدير للمملكه العربيه السعوديه
على استضافه هذه القمه من الاولى من نوعها
متمنيه العمالقه كل النجاح والتوفيق
صاحب السمو الملكي في جذب الانتباه الى
مطلب ان تكون الكلمات لخمسه دقائق في
الاحاديث القادم شكرا جزيلا صاحب السمو
الملكي
[تصفيق]
اشكركم على السيد احمد ابو الغيط على
كلمته والان اعلن اتهام راس مثل حكم القمه
العربيه الصينيه الاولى وبدل جسد العمل
الاولى
الان ادعوا فخامه الرئيس عبد الفتاح
السيسي رئيس جمهوريه مصر العربيه لالقاء
كلمته
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
اخي صاحب السمو الملكي الامير محمد بن
سلمان ولي عهد ورئيس وزراء المملكه
العربيه السعوديه الشرقيه فخامه الرئيس
سجن بنك رئيس جمهوريه الصين الشعبيه اصحاب
الجلاله والفخامه والسمو ملوك الرؤساء
وامراء الدول العربيه الشقيقه معالي السيد
احمد ابو الغيط امين عام جامعه الدول
العربيه السيدات والساده اعضاء الوفود
الحضور الكريم السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
وبركاته
اسمحوا لي في مستهلكلمات ان اعبر عن الشكر
والامتنان والتقدير
للمملكه العربيه السعوديه لكرم الضيافه
وحفاوت الاستقبال وتهنئه المملكه العربيه
السعوديه الشقيقه باستضافه القمه الاولى
بين الدول العربيه والصين
الاخوه والاخوات نعلم جميعا ما يجمع دولنا
وشعوبنا من روابط ممتده عبر التاريخ تدعوا
لنا المجتمعت اليوم اسست الحضاره
الانسانيه الحديثه التي نعيشها حين ترافقت
الحضارات الفرعونيه وحضرت بلاد ما بين
النهرين وغيرها من حضارات منطقتنا العربيه
مع الحضاره الصينيه القديمه لتمثل شموسا
بازغه لترشد الانسانيه في مهدها وتساعدها
على ان تخطوا خطواتها الاولى
وتقطع عزازه الشراكه بين شعوبنا وبلادنا
مع نهود الحضرتين العربيه والاسلاميه
فتلاقى مع الحضاره الصينيه العريقه على
قاعده المدينه وراسخه من التواصل الانساني
والثقافي والتجاري بما كفل تبادل الافكار
وتلاقي الثقافات فقدمت بلداننا منذ فجر
التاريخ الى العالم مفهوم الدوله الوطنيه
بكامل اركانيها وتمسكت في سع نحو التقدم
الحضاري بالتوازن بين الجانبين المادي
والروحي للوجود الانساني
ثم خذنا معا في التاريخ الحديث معارك
متعدده من اجل التحرر والاستقلال السياسي
ومن اجل التنميه وبناء الاقتصاد وما زلنا
نعمل على قرن نظام عالمي اكثر عداله يتاسس
على القيم الانسانيه وقواعد القانون
الدولي وصولا الى التعاون العربي الصيني
المتمر من خلال المنتدى العربي الصيني
والياته المختلفه الذي يجمعنا اليوم
ولقد تاسست التعاون العربي الصيني على
تعظيم المناعه والمصالح المشتركه ومواجهه
التحديات التنمويه وتعزيز التعاون جنوب
جنوب وتقديم اولويات حفظ الامن والسلم
الدوليين وصيانه النظام الدولي المرتكز
على ميثاق الامم المتحده والقانون الدولي
وايجاد حلول سياسيه سلميه للازمات الدوليه
والاقليميه واحترام خصوصيه الشعوب وحقها
في الاختيار دون وصايه او تدخلات الخارجيه
ورده تاسيس في قضايا حقوق الانسان وتعزيز
حوار الحضارات وتقارب الثقافات والتعاون
في مواجهه تحديات التغيير المناخي وتفشل
بها وانتشار ساحه الدمار الشامل ومكافحه
خطر الارهاب والافكار المتطرفه كل ما وجدت
وانما كانت على تلك الاسس يكتسب معهن
اليوم رمزيه واهميه خاصه لاسيما في هذا
التوقيت الدقيق الذي يشهد متغيرات دوليه
وازمات عالميه متعاقبه
قيمه تحديات بالغه الخطوره امام التحديات
الجسام ترتفع اهميه الساعات كافه قدرات
التعاون الكامله بين الاصدقاء والاشقاء
ناسيه ما اذا كانت قائمه على اسس صلبه
للتفاهم والتنسيق كتلك القائمه بين العالم
العربي والصين
اصحاب الجلاله والفخامه والسموم العالم
الاخطر ما يواجهه العالم بخاصه الدول
الناميه اليوم وازمه الغذاء وتابعتها وهم
يدفعنا لتوثيق الشراكه العربيه الصينيه في
مواجهه هذا التحدي عبر تعزيز قطر التعاون
متعدد الاطراف لتطوير الاستجابه الدوليه
السريعه والفعاله لحاجات الدول الناميه
والعمل في اطار التعاون جنوب جنوب لتطوير
الزراعه والصناعات الغذائيه ونقل وتوطين
التكنولوجيا وبناء القدرات وتحسين البنيه
التحتيه في المناطق الريفيه ونقل
تكنولوجيا الزراعه ونظم الراي الحديثه
المستدامه ولقد اثقلت هذه الازمات كذلك
كهل دوليها وموزنتها الحكوميه وهو يتطلب
دفع المجتمع الدولي لتخفيف الديون على
الدول التي تعاني من ارتفاع فاتوره
استيراد الغذاء والطاقه مع العمل على
تعزيز التعاون لنظام التجاري متعدد
الاطراف القائم على القواعد وعدد صياغه
قطر حكمه الاقتصاد الدولي
المؤسسات الماليه الدوليه لتكون اكثر
عداله وشفافيه فتشمل الجميع ولا تستبعد
الدول الناميه وتكون اكثر استجابه في
التحديات التي تواجهها تلك الدول وان يعاد
تركيز مهامها من المستدامه وفي القلب منها
القضاء على الفقر ورغم التحديات العالميه
التي اشارته لبعضها والاستقطاب الدوله
الحاد نجاحه الرئاسه المصريه للقمه
العالميه للمناخ قد كنت 7 في اقناع
المجتمع الدولي بالتوصل الى توافق حول عدد
كبير من الامور الحيويه على راسها انشاء
صندوق الخسائر والاضرار والانتفاق على
خطوات جاده لتفعيل وتنفيذ التعاهدات
الدوليه الخاصه بالتمويل اضافه الى
اجراءات التكيف والتخفيف وذلك على نحو
المتوازن وانني اثق بان يتعاوننا جميعا
طوال فتره الرئاسه المصريه سواء ثنائيا او
من خلال منتدى التعاون العربي الصيني
سيكفر تنفيذ التعاهدات الدوليه الخاصه
بالبناء وعلى راسها ت متعلقه بالتمويل من
جانب الدول المتقدمه اصحاب الجلاله
والفخامه والسموم لقد تجسدت ارادتنا في
تعزيز التعاون المؤسسه المشترك مع تدشين
منتدى التعاون العربي الصيني عام 2004
وتبلغ اليوم تلك الاراده ذروتها باجتماع
القمه العربيه الصينيه الاولى ولا شك اننا
جميعا لانه داخل جهدا من اجل تعزيز ودعم
الشركات القائمه بيننا وعلى راسها الشراكه
في اطار مبادرات الحزام والطريق والتنميه
الدوليه وما تحمله من الفرس لتعميق
التعاون العربي الصيني وزياده فرصه
استثمار في مختلف المجالات وانني ادعوا
لجميع اليوم الاعتبار ان اعتقاد هذه القمه
بمثابه علامه انطلاق جديده للتعاون
الاقتصادي بين العالم العربي والصين حيث
ان الصين وراءهم كونها بالفعل الشريك
التجاري الرئيسي لعدد كبير من دولنا
العربيه فضلا عما يجمعنا من تعاون
الاستثماري جوهري الا ان افاق التعاون بين
بل مننا لازالت رحمه وبامكاننا تحقيق
المزيد والمزيد في مجالات اقتصاديه وتمويه
وتكنولوجيه عده وان افاق التعاون العربي
الصيني وفرص تطويره لا تقتصر فقط على الشق
الاقتصادي والتنموي بل تمتد للافاق
السياسيه والثقافيه فقد كانت السياسات
الصينيه المتوازنه المتوازنه تجاه مختلف
القضيه العربيه بشكل عام وتجاه القضيه
الفلسطينيه بشكل خاص ودعم الجانب الصيني
لحق الفلسطيني المشروع في اقامه الدوله
الفلسطينيه على خطوط الرابع من يونيو
1967 وعاصمتها القدس الشرقيه محل تقدير
واحترام بالغين في العالم العربي ولقد بقى
دله الدول العربيه تلك المواقف الصينيه
المتزنه الدائمه بمواقض مسانده للصين
ومتفهمه لقضاياها
وان هذا التقارب في الرؤى والمنطلقات
تشجعنا
المزيد من التنسيق اذا مختلف القضايا
الدوليه والاقليميه ذات الاولويه لكل منا
والسنادا على قاعده احترام سياده الدول
وعدم التدخل في شؤون الداخليه يمكننا
التعاون لبحث سبل المعالجه الازمات في
سوريا وليبيا واليمن وغيرها من الملفات
وفي مواجهه الارهاب بكافه صوره واشكاله
وانهاء معاناه الشعوب واحلال الامن
والسلامه وتقديم الولايات التنميه على
الصراع والتنازل الاخوه والاخوات اسمحوا
لي ان اعيد التاكيد مره اخرى على قضيه اثق
انها تعرقنا جميعا لما تحمله من قيود على
التنميه وتفرضه من مخاطر
ترقى الى حد التهديدات الوجديه الا وهي
قضيه الامن المائي العربي وانني لهذا
ادعوا الى وضع هذه المساله على راسه
اولويات التعاوننا المستقبلي لان منتدى
التعاون العربي الصيني بحث كيفيه التعامل
لمواجهه هذا التحدي بمختلف الادوات
التكنولوجيه والاقتصاديه والسياسيه كمان
انني اود ان اجدد الدعوه للاشقاء في
اثيوبيا الى الانقراض بحسن النيه الواجب
مع مصر والسودان للتواصل لاتفاق القانوني
ملزم
للاجيال الحالات والمستقبليه حقها في
التنميه ويجنبها ما يهدد استقرارها
اقول ان هو هذا التاريخ الفريد الذي تميز
به التواصل العربي الصينيه الانساني
والحضاري الدافئ ومتعدد القواسم المشتركه
في الرؤى والمفاهيل وبما يضمه منتدى
التعاون العربي الصيني من اليات وبرامج
ومقترحات فكل ثقه ان العقاد قيمتنا
الحاليه سياتي دفعه ملموسه للتعاون العربي
الصيني بكافه سوريا واننا حين نجتمع مجددا
في المستقبل الكريم
سنكون قد انجزنا الكثير وقطعنا اشواطا
اضافيه في مسارات التعاون جميعا وفقنا
الله جميعا لما فيه الخير لما فيه الخير
والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
[تصفيق]
اشكرك فخامه الرئيس عبد الفتاح السيسي على
كلمته والان ادعوا فخامه الرئيس محمد ولد
الشيخ رئيس جمهوريه اسلاميه الموريتانيه
للقاء كلمه تفضل
ولي العهد رئيس مجلس الوزراء الامير محمد
بن سلمان
صاحب الفخامه السيد الشهيد رئيس جمهوريه
الصين الشعبيه
اصحاب الجلاله والفخامه والسموحه والمعاني
معالي السيد احمد ابو الغيط الامين العام
لجامعه الدول العربيه ايها الساده
والسيدات
يطيبوا لي بدايه ان اتوجه بخالص التهنئه
الى صاحب الجلاله الملك سلمان بن عبد
العزيز خادم الحرمين الشريفين والى صاحب
السمو الملكي ولي العهد رئيس مجلس الوزراء
الامير محمد بن سلمان
الاحتضان المملكه العربيه السعوديه
الشقيقه للقمه الاولى لمنتدى التعاون
العربي الصيني
المرافقه من حسن الاستقبال وكرم الضيافه
العربيه الاصيله
واهنئ كذلك صاحب الفخامه السيد سجن بينك
رئيس جمهوريه الصين الشعبيه السابقه لما
يبين عنه يوم بعد اخر من حرص على تعزيز
التعاون العربي الصيني واصرار على تقويه
الروابط التي تجمعه الطرفين
اصحاب الجلاله والفخامه والسمو المعالي ان
الدول العربيه وجمهوريه الصين الشعبيه
تجمعها قيم مشتركه كثيره
لتشتركان في نفس السعي الى تعزيز التعاون
بينهما والى بناء تنميه مستدامه شامله
تحقق الازدهار الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه
لسائر الشعوب في ظل امن وسلام دائما
ويشكلون العقاد هذه القمه هذه القمه
الاولى على مستوى القاده
التعاون العربي الصيني تكريس لاراده
السياسيه المشتركه في ارساء نموذج
تعاوانيا
يكون دعامه لشراكه استراتيجيه راسيه
الاساس وتحولا النوعيه في المسار العام
لهذا المنتدى
لقد تمكن منتدى التعاون الصيني العربي من
بناء جسر المتين للتعاون بين الصين والدول
العربيه بفضل ما تبناهم من مقاربه تشاركيه
تعتمد مبدا المصالح المشتركه والمنافع
المتبادله في اطار من الاحترام المتبادل
ومن مراعاه كل طرف خصوصيه الاخر
وتنعكس قوه الترابط بين دول بين دول
العربيه والجمهور والجمهوريه الصين
الشعبيه
الدوليه سواء تعلق الامر بدعمنا لمبدا
الصين الواحده او تعلق بدعم الصيني
لقضايانا العربيه المحوريه
كما تنعكس كذلك في شركتنا ضمن مبادره
الحزام والطريق التي تفتح امكانات كبيره
لتعميق التعاون العربي الصيني لخلق
الديناميكيات اقتصاديه جديده وكذلك بتكثيف
التعاون والتبادل الثنائي
وبهذا الخصوص فان التعاون الثنائي متنوع
ووطيد بين الجمهوريه الاسلاميه
الموريتانيه وجمهوريه الصين الشعبيه
اللتين تجمعهما علاقات صداقه متينه ولا
تتطوروا بالطراد خدمه للمصالح الحيويه
للشعب بين الصديقين وللسلم والامن
الدوليين
فقد وكبت جمهوريه الصين الشعبيه بلادنا
منذ استقلالها في مطلع الستينيات القرن
الماضي وقدمت لها الدعم السياسيه
والتنمويه وقد تعز ذلك وتضاعف في السنوات
الاخيره
وتمثل الصين اليوم الشركه التجاريه الاول
لموريتانيا ويشمل التعاون الصيني
الموريتاني مجالات متنوعه كلبين التحتيه
والصيد والصحه وغيرها وانني لا اثمن عاليا
الدعم لمنتوما التي تقدمه الصين لبلادنا
وفي هذا السياره
انتم بتعملوا بلادي عاليا اعلان الرئيس
السجن اليوم في خطابه امام هذه القمه اني
الاعمال النيه المشتركه التي تتعلق
بالتنميه الامن الغذائي الصحه التنميه
الخضراء الابتكار والطاقه والحوار
الحضارات وتاهيل الشباب والامن والاستقرار
والتي هي كلها تتماشى مع اولوياتنا
الوطنيه
اصحاب الجلال والفخامه والمعاني
لان الصعوبه الله في اقليم الدوليه الراهن
بما يتزاحم فيه من ازمات امنيه واقتصاديه
وبيئيه حاده يجعلنا نتطلعوا الى ان تساهم
هذه القمه الى جانب بقيه اليات التعاون
القائمه في تعميق الحوار الاستراتيجي
العربيه الصيني للاسلام في رفعه مختلف
التحديات التي نواجهها جميعا تقويه لرابطه
المصير
تلك التحديات ضروره ترسيخ الامن والسلامه
في وطننا العربي
وهو ما لم يتم الا باقامه دوله فلسطينيه
مستقله عاصمتها القدس الشرقيه وفقا
لقرارات الشرعيه الدوليه ومبادره السلام
العربيه
كما يتطلب تسريع مسارات التسويه السليمه
للازمات القائمه في ليبيا وسوريا واليمن
وفقا المرجعيات الاقليميه والدوليه المتفق
عليها ومنع التنظيمات الارهابيه من
استغلال الحاله الاضطراب الامني لمواصله
تهديد الامن القومي العربي
الصيني
في رفع التحدي البيئي عن طريق دعم
الاجراءات التي يتخذها العديد من دول
العربيه في هذا الشان كم مبادره الشرق
الاوساط الاخضر الرائده التي اطلقها صاحب
السمو الملكي الامير محمد بن سلمان وكان
مشروع الهيدروجين الاخضر الذي تعمل على
اطلاقه بلادنا
هذا علاوه على الدوري الهامل للمنتدى في
رفع مستوى التبادلات البينيه والاسامي في
قدره اقتصاداتنا العربيه على خلق القيمه
المضافه وتسريع النمو لتحقيق رفاه المشترك
واجمالا فان الاعمال التي نعقدها على
متمرد التعاون العربي الصيني عريضه
ستعزز دوره وترفعه من فعاليته في بناء
تنميه مستديمه وارسال امن وسلام دائمين
للدول العربيه وللجمهوريه
الصين الشعبيه وللعالم عموما اشكركم
والسلام عليكم
[تصفيق]
فخامه الرئيس محمد ولد الشيخ على كلمته
والانا ادعو فخامه الرئيس محمود عباس رئيس
دوله فلسطين لالقاء كلمته فليتفضل
صاحب السمو الملكيه الامير محمد بن سلمان
ولي العهد
ورئيس الوزراء للمملكه العربيه السعوديه
معالي الامين العام لجامعه الدول العربيه
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
[موسيقى]
لاخي خادم الحرمين الشريفين الملك سلمان
بن عبد العزيز ولا اخي ولي العهد صاحب
السمو الملكي الامير محمد بن سلمان
والحكومه المملكه العربيه السعوديه على
استضافه هذه القمه التاريخيه والهامه التي
تزوجت سنوات من الحوار العربي الصيني في
اطار المنتدى التعاون وعلى المستويات كافه
ونحيي جميع القاده الدول والرؤساء الوفود
من الدول العربيه والمشاركين في هذه القمه
ونقدر جهودهم المتواصله في نجاح هذه
الشراكه الاستراتيجيه مع الصين كما يسعدني
ان ارحب
بفخامه الرئيس
كل الاحترام والتقدير
متمنيين الفخامته التوفيق والسداد في
تحقيق طموحات الشعب الفلسطيني صديق نحن
مزيده من التقدم والتطور
ويؤكد لكم صديقنا فخامه الرئيس ان دوله
فلسطين التي تؤمن بعداله الموقفكم
لدعم سياستها
الصين الواحده وفي مواجهه الحملات التي
تستهدفها في المحافل الدوليه
وبهذه المناسبه المعبر فخامه الرئيس
الصيني عن عميق الشكرنا لرؤيته
ولمواقف الصين الثابته والداعمه لحقوق
الشعب الفلسطيني
ولكل ما تقدمه من مساعدات وبرامج تعاون
تنمويه وهي لفتاه مقدره لن ننساها شعبنا
الفلسطيني
ان هذه القمه الاولى من نوعها
المزيد من جسور التعاون على اساس التبادل
الاقتصادي والاستثمارات
وفي اطار مبادره الحزام والطريق مع
التاكيد على الطرق الاربعه
لبناء المجتمع الصيني العربي للمستقبل
المشترك ومن خلال التمسك بالاستقلاليه
والسياده وعدم التدخل بالشؤون الداخليه
على ما اعلنه الرئيسيه باهميه التعاون في
المجالات الثمانيه
المشتركه في التنميه والامن الغذائي
والصحه والتنميه الخضراء والابتكارات
وامن الطاقه والحوار بين الحضارات
وتاهلات وتاهيل الشمام والامن والاستقرار
والمضيق دوما نحو بناء مستقبلين وتعاونا
عربيا صينيه مشترك اصحاب الجلاله والفخامه
الاسرائيلي جازما على ارض الدوله فلسطين
بعاصمتها القدس الشرقيه دوله محاسبه بعد
تشغيل اكثر من نصف الشعب الفلسطيني من
ارضه منذ اكثر من اربعه 74 عاما وهم الذين
يشكرون حاليا اكثر من سبعه ملايين ملاذي
وامر يفرض تساؤلات العده حول الجديه
النظام الدولي الذي يصنع
لسلطات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي بمواصله
انتهاك القانون الدولي
وانشاء نظام
التمييز العنصريا كامل اركان
ومواصله
الاعمال الاحاديه
والاستيطان الاستعماري والقتل والحصان
والتهذير وهدم المنازل وتغيير هويه مدينه
القدس
مدينه القدس وعدم احترام الوضع التاريخي
والسباحه المقدسات
الاسلاميه والمسيحيه فيها
وحجز الاموال
اموالنا في ظل صمت دوليا
المعايير وسياسه شريعه الغاب هذا النظام
الدولي الذي لم ينجح في تطبيق اين من
قراراته الامميه نحو الشعب الفلسطيني
والتي تزيد عن الالف قرار في الجمعيه
العامه ومجلس الامن وحقوق الانسان
لابد
لماذا
الايام
لوجود شريك في اسرائيل
يؤمنوا بحل الدولتين على اساس الشرعيه
الدوليه
والاتفاقات المتوقع ونبذ العنف والارهاب
وهي المبادئ التي نحن ملتزمون بها
ونعمل بموجبها واننا ندعو في هذا الاطار
المجتمع الدولي الى عدم التعامل مع ايه
حكومه الاسرائيليه
لا تعترفوا بهذه المبادئ والقيم
وبالرغم من كل ذلك
فاننا نتخلي عن
لن نتخلى عن الالتزام بالقانون الدولي
وانا اطلع في هذه الظروف الصعبه
ان تواصل ايها الاخوه
الدعم الدولي لتنفيذ قرارات الشرعيه
الدوليه
ومبادره السلام العربيه
للحصول على الاعتراف بدوله فلسطين وعلى
العلويه الكامله في الامم المتحده وعقد
مؤتمر دوليا السلام
وتامين الحمايه الدوليه للشعب
الفلسطيني
وتطبيق قرارات الشرعيه الدوليه الخاصه
بالقضيه الفلسطينيه
وكذلك وكذلك
قرارات الجمعيه العامه
181 الذي اخذ في عام 47
و194 الذي اخذ عام
وهم القراران اللذان
كنا شرطين لقبول اسرائيل
كعضو في الامم المتحده والى الان لم
تنفذهما ولم تقبل بهما هذا القرار
لابد محاسبه اسرائيل اما ان تقبل بهما او
لا تكون عضو في الامم المتحده كما يؤكد
على وجوب الاعتذار
والتعويض من بريطانيا وامريكا للشعب
الفلسطيني
بسبب واحد من الفار كامل
وفك الانتداب وكذلك الاعتذار والتعويض
بالاسرائيل عن مرتكبته ابالا النكبه من
المذابح 51 مذبحه في عام 48
وتدمير مئات الكره الفلسطينيه 500 قريه
مساحتها عن الوجود
وتهجير مئات الالاف 1950,000 لاجئ من
بيوتهم وفي الختام اشكركم جميعا واحييكم
ايها الاخوه القاده على دعمكم ومواقفكم
تجاه فلسطين
واكلين لكم جميعا باننا سنبقى فاعلين في
خدمه التعاون العربي الصيني
ومسانده الدول وشعوب من طاقتنا لتحقيق
الامن والاستقرار والسلام
ومحاربه الارهاب في منطقه همم
وفي العالم
ونرفع بهذه المناسبه
تحياتنا
لخادم الحرمين الملك سلمان بن عبد العزيز
متمنين له الصحه والعمر المديد والسلام
عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
[تصفيق]
اشكرك فخامه الرئيس محمود عباس على كلمته
والان ادعوا فخمه الرئيس قيس سعيد رئيس
جمهوريه التونسيه للقاء كلمه تفضل
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
والحمد لله
حتى نلقاه وبعد ان نلقاه
والصلاه والسلام على رسول الله
صاحب السمو الملكي
الامير محمد بن سلمان بن عبد العزيز ال
سعود
ولي العهد رئيس مجلس الوزراء للمملكه
العربيه السعوديه
الصديقه
اصحابك جلاله والفخامه والسمو
معالي الامين العام
لجامعه الدول العربيه
اسمح لي
في هذه الكلمه
ان اتقدمه باخلص عبارات الشكر
لخادم الحرمين الشريفين
الملك سلمان بن عبد العزيز ال سعود
والى فخامه الرئيس شيء جيل بين رئيسي
جمهوريه الصين الشعبيه الشقيقه لما يليه
من اهميه
لتطوير التعاون العربي الصيني
نلتقي اليوم في هذه القمه
الاولى من نوعها
وفوق هذه الارض الطيبه الامنه
وجعلها الله دائما امنه
شكرا لمن نظمه هذه القمه
وشكرا لمن استضافها
وشكرا لمن اختار لها
عنوان
من اجل السلام والتنميه
لانه لا تنميه بدون السلام
ولا سلامه للجميع في غياب تنميه العادله
في كل المستويات
انها عقارب الساعه تدور بسرعه
والزمن هو غير الزمن
اثر السقوط حائط برلين
جديده
لبناء جديد
تغيب فيه الاسلاك الشائكه
والجدران الفاصله
والمحاور المتقلبه
لقد عانت الانسانيه كلها
طويلا من التوزيع غير العادل
للثروات
وعانت من الحروب ومن المجاعات
وما زالت
للاسفك الدماء وتسيل
وما زال الاحتلال شاسما على ارض فلسطين
وما سالت شعوب باكملها
يموت فيها عشرات الالاف من الجوع والعطش
تتناقلها وسائل الاعلام ولكن دون اثر في
الواقعي والفعل هذا فضلا عن الحروب
الاهليه
وعلى الارهاب
افضل من هذه الاوضاع
ليصداده وحشيه
وازداده للاسف انتشارا
ومن دواعي لاسه
انك كثيرا من البلدان في العالم
لا تسالوا
بعد اكثر من سته او سبعه عقود من
استقلالها
توصف بانها ناميه
ولكنها لم تنمو
وتوصف بانها فقير
وازداد الفقر فيها انتشاره
الساده بشاعتا في عديدا منها
وتضمه الاستعانه عن وصفهاميه
بالدولي ذات الهشاشه
فالى متى
ستبقى في طريقها المسدوده نحو النمو
والى اين يسير العالم كله
لو بقيت اسباب الفقر
قائمه داخل الدول وعلى الصعيد العالمي على
حد السواء
ان الانسان هو الانسان
في كل مكان
ولا هو نفس الحقوق في الحياه الكريمه في
كل الاوطان
لذلك
في هذه المرحله الجديده من تاريخ
الانسانيه
يجب ان تكون حقيقيه
ولا سلام
الحمد لله
نلتقي اليوم في هذه القمه
وفوق هذه الارض الطيبه من اجلي
فتح طريق جديده في التاريخ
في السنوات الستين اذا كانت قد بلغت مداها
وانقلبت على ذاتها
فالواجب
يقتضي
انقارب هذه التحولات
بمقاربات جديده
بعيدا عن المحاور
وبمنئه عن تحالفات
يرتب فيها البشر
ترتيبا تفاضليه
او ترتب فيها الشعوب كما كانت تركب
في القرون الماضيه الحركه
ولم تتسبب بلداننا
[موسيقى]
في القرون الماضيه
وفي الاعوام السالفه
لا في ثقب طبقه الاوزون ولا في البقر
المجنون ولا في الانحباس الحراري او نفوق
الطيور ولكن شعوبنا هي التي دفعت الثمن
دفعته
باهظا
وساده البؤس والاملاق
وساده الهشاشه كما يصطرح عليها اليوم اذا
كان هناك اصرار على الابقاء على هذا
المصطلح الذي لا يفيد ان يتغير في الواقع
ونحن نجتمع اليوم في هذه القمه العربيه
الصينيه لنغير هذا الواقع ولا نبحث عن
مصطلحات جديده وعن مفاهيم جديده وعن افكار
مختلفه عن الافكار التي سادت ولم تؤدي في
كثيرا من الاحيان الا لمزيد الحرمان والى
مسيد البؤس والفقر والى مزيد الحروب والى
مسيدي
مالي حق الشعوب في تقرير مصيرها بنفسها
واولها حق الشعب الفلسطيني في ارض فلسطين
وعاصمته القدس الشريف
علينا ان نوافقه
في شق طريق جديده في التاريخ
في الصين
العبور فوق
نصنعها معا
انطلاقا من نفس القيم
وانطلاقا من نفس الاراده
حتى لا
تتواصل
التي نعيشها الى حد اليوم وحتى ينتهي
البؤس وحتى تتوقفه الحروب
واستحضروا
حكمته
الصينيين القدامى والجدد
وحكمه العرب
الذين حفظوا والموجودين اليوم
نحن لا تنقصنا للحكمه ولا الاراده
المشتركه في بناء عالم جديد
على المستوى العالمي والامن والسلام
للانسانيه جماعه والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله
وبركاته
اشكر فخامه الرئيس قيس سعيد على كلمته
وارجو من الجميع الالتزام بالخمس دقائق
كوقت الكلمه والان ادعوا فخامه الرئيس
عثمان غزالي رئيس جمهوريه القمر المتحده
للقاء كلمته فليتفضل
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الحمد لله رب العالمين والصلاه والسلام
على اشرف المرسلين
سيدنا وحبيبنا مولانا محمد وعلى اله وصحبه
وسلم
صاحب السمو الملكي الامير محمد بن سلمان
بن عبد العزيز ال سعود
فخامه الرئيس رئيس الجمهوريه
اصحاب الجلاله والسمو والفم والفخامه
معالي الاستاذ احمد امين العام لجماعه
الدول العربيه
اسيادتي الحضور الكريم السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله وبركاته
اسمحوا لي اولا ان اقدم الى اخي
خادم الحرمين الشريفين الملك سلمان بن عبد
العزيز ال سعود حفظه الله ورعاه من خلال
جلالته الى حكم
شقيقه خالص الشكر
المرافق
الى البلد الكريم الملك عبد العزيز
السعوديه
كما وحيد
القمه التي نتوقع منها بثقه
العلاقات العربيه الصينيه نحو افاق افضل
الاسهال والتقدم في مختلف مجالات التعاون
المشترك بيننا وبين جمهوريه الصين الشعبيه
انني لا يقيني من ان هذا القمه ستسهم في
مباراه الرئه وسياساته بشان قضايا اثريه
والاقليميه والدوليه ذات الاهتمام المشترك
وفي تعزيل الحوار السياسي الموافق المشترك
التي تهدف الى حمايه المصالح العربيه
والسينيه ودعم السلام الدوليه والامن
وتحقيق التنميه المستدامات في جميع مجالات
كما انني مقتنع لان هذا ذات الاولى لقمه
العربيه السوريه التي تضيفها المملكه
العربيه الشقيقه بالاضافه السياسيه
والاقتصاديه
بين الدول العربيه والجمهور الصين الشعبيه
في خلق روحي من جديد للشراكه العربيه
الصينيه على اساس مسكين
وواضحه تماكد الطريق سيا
تعاون والتقامل اقتصادي ناجح ونعمل ان
تكون حافظه قويه
من العلاقات العربيه الصينيه نحو افاق
اوسعم بما يخدم مصلحه المشتركه للطرفين في
الواقع على مدارس السبعين عامه واكثر
الماضيه منذ التاسيس السوري الجديده كانت
الصين والدول العربيه دائما تحترم برده هل
تعامل بعضا على قدر المساواه لذا فان هذه
قيمه السنه العربيه الاولى هي حدث كبير
وخطوه مهمه نتخذها منذ التزام
رئيسيين الشعبيه بمضاعفه تبادل التجاري مع
الدول الخليج بين عام 2014
و2013 ومن هنا فانني يحير روح صداقه
والاستبداد العمل يادا بيدن لبناء المجتمع
العربي الصينيه الذي نريده من اجل بقى
للمستقبل المشترك زهير تتدلى هذه الروحه
في التعاون المروج الذي تمكن من ترسيخه ثم
كافه
التعاون الناشي بين ادفع في الصينيه
والعربيه انا اساسي المنفعه المبادلات
وشركات المبيحه الجنايني الحضور الكريم
اسمحوا لي ان اذكر هنا بان بلدي هجوم
الاخوات المتحده كانت تلعب فيه سلاحاتي
اقتصاديات
جديده بهدف تنفيذ رؤيته نوح
مرتبه الدول الصاعده لحلولي عام 2030 في
ايطاليا
جزر القمر من فيلم تامر وشركاه في باريس
في عام 19
بجناحه كبير في هذه المؤتمر وبعد
باريس نظره الحكومه القمريه
اجتماعا رافع مستوى بشان متابعه مؤتمر
شركاء التمنيه في القمر كان هذا الاجتماع
على مستوى توقظنا ومكان في تسليغه تمديد
جديده لعدد اطلاق العمليات تجديد وتعبئتين
الاعلانات خدمه العمل للتنميه والتنفيذ
الفاعل يا اخي تعتذر القمر الصناعه لحل
العين افندي كمان ما كان هذا اجتماع من
مشاركه توجهات
الاستعجيه الحكومه التي تلاقي التمييع
المستلمه في البلاد وعيالاتها الى مسار
ظهور في تعرض جنده الاتحاد الافريقيه حتى
عام 1033
الامم المتحده حتى عام 2030 ذلك اود ان
يشاهد الجميع في اطار هذه القمه الصينيه
العربيه
مساعدتنا في تنفيذ مشاري وتوفيات هذا
الاجتماع
التعيز هذه الفرصه يعبر هنا انا خارج
السوق عند عماني الدول العربيه وصنادق
العربيه
المتخصصات المشاركتها الفعالات المفتوحه
واشكر جمهوريه السنه الشعبيه على دمها
متواصل التمنيه لمشار امتنا والله ولي
التوفيق والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
[تصفيق]
فخامه الرئيس الدكتور اسماعيل عمر
رئيس جمهوريه جيبوتي للقاء كلمه فليتفضل
شكرا
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين والصلاه والسلام على رسول الله
الامين سيدنا وحبيبنا محمد صلى الله عليه
وسلم صاحب الصمود الملكيه امير محمد بن
سلمان عبد العزيز
ال سعود ولي العهد ورئيس مجلس الوزراء في
المملكه العربيه السعوديه الشقيقه صاحب
الفخامه الرئيس السيسي الرئيس جمهوريه
الصين الشعبيه الصديقه اصحاب الجلاله
والفخامه والسمو معالي الامين العام
لجامعه الدول العربيه اصحاب المعالي
والسعاده حضرات السيدات والساده والسلام
عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
خادم الحرمين الشريفين الملك سلمان بن عبد
العزيز ال سعود ولي العهد الامين صاحب
الرسول الملكيه الامير محمد بن سلمان بن
عبد العزيز سعود والشعب السعودي الشقيق
على احتضان القمه العربيه الصينيه
والاعداد للجيد والمتميز لانجاحها وعلى
حفاوه الاستقبال وكرم الضيافه الذين حضنين
بهما منذ ان وضعت اقدامنا ارض هذا البلد
العزيز المليار اصحاب الجلاله والفخامه
والسموم الحضور الكريم اننا نجتمع اليوم
في قدم مرحله تاريخيه هامه مفعمه بالامل
والعمل البناء حيث نلتقي في سياق اول
القمه تنحقدوا بين الجانبين بين العربي
والصيني مما يؤسس العهد الجديد في مسيره
التعاون الوثيق والشراكه الاستراتيجيه
القائمه بين الطرفين
ولا يسعون الا ان نعبر عن ارتياحنا البالغ
لهذا التطور الكبير اللافت الذي يجسد
الاراده المشتركه الاكيده والعزم الراسخ
على الارتقائي باليات العمل الجماعي في
سبيل تحقيق الاهداف والغايات الساميه
المشتركه حضرات السيدات والساده
تفسر قيمتنا فرصه ثانيه
لتقديم التقدم المحرز في المجالات التعاون
المثمر القائم بين الجانبين العربي
والصيني واستشراق اثار من جديده جديده
للشراكه التي تربط بين الطرفين وفي هذا
السدد فان من الاهميه بمكان
وروح الصداقه والتعاون بين الدول العربيه
والصين والعمل معا من اجل بناء مجتمع عربي
صينيه متازر ومتضامن يعفوا الى مستقبل
المشترك اكثر اشراقا ويحث الخطى بكل ثقه
وثبات نحو نحو العصر الجديد مستله من
التاريخ الطويل الحافل الذي يميز العلاقات
العربيه السينيه المتجزره
التخصص على على تسخير كل الامكانيات لخدمه
التنميه المستدامه ونحيي في هذا الصياغه
المبادرات التنمويه الخلاقه التي اطلقها
فخامه الرئيس السيسي بين من قبيل مبادره
الحزام والطريق ومبادره التنميه العالميه
والتي تعكس بدا اهتمام جمهوريه الصين
الشعبيه الصديقه بدفع تنميه العالميه الى
مستويات جديده اكثر استماع استدامه وشمريه
واتصالا بذلك فانني اوده الاشاره بالدوري
البارز الذي تقوم به الصين في الدفع عمليه
التنميه في جمهوريه جيبوتي حيث
توجد بين البلدين سراكه بناءه مكنت من رفع
العلاقات الثنائيه الى مستوى غير مسبوق
فضلا عن تنفيذ المشاريع التنمويه مشتركه
مشتركه املاقه ليس على الصعيد الوطني بل
على المستوى الاقليمي ايضا الامر الذي فتح
افاق الرحبه واسعه امام عمليه التحديث
والتحول في جيبوتي وفي منطقه القرن
الافريقي باصله
اصحاب الجلاله والفخامه والسموم في ظل
التحولات الدوليه المتلاحقه او التحديات
المتزايده فاننا مدعومه اكثر من اي وقت
مضى الى تعزيز التعاون والتنسيق المشترك
لمواكبه هذه المتغيرات وايجاد حلول
مبتكره لمختلف التحديات ونؤكد في هذا
المضمار على اهميه الدور الذي تلعبه الصين
كعامل توازن على صعيد العلاقات الدوليه
انطلاقا من المكانه المركزيه التي تحتلها
في النظام الدولي وفي مسيره التقدم العلمي
كما نشدد على اهميه التي تمثلها الدول
العربيه كم مجموعه دوليه ذات موقع
الجغرافيه فريد وثقل سياسيا وحضور تاريخيا
مشهود ولا شك ان ذلك يجعل التنسيق المشترك
بين الجانبين في المحافل الاقليميه
والدوليه امرا حيويه يطفي اثرا حاسما على
القضايا المهمه وفي الاطار الذاتي نعبر عن
ارشادتنا وتقديرنا للمواقف الصينيه
المبدئيه والثابته الداعمه لمصالح الامه
العربيه وقضاياها العاجله وفي مقدمتها
القضيه الفلسطينيه كما نجدد
المساندنتها لمبدا الصيني الواحده التي
توافق عليه المجتمع الدولي كاس اساسا
للعلاقات الدبلوماسيه بين الصين والدول
الاخرى وفي الختام يجددوا الاعراب عن عميق
شكرا وتقدير للمملكه العربيه السعوديه
الشقيقه ملكا وحكومه وشعبا على تنظيمها
المحكم لهذه القمه
التي تشكل محطه بارزه في مسير الشراكه
الاسترات جيه بين الدول العربيه والصين
متطلعين الى ما ستصحروا عنه من نتائج
نامروا ان تفضي الى تحقيق الامال المشتركه
والدفع العلاقات العربيه الصينيه الى
فضائل ارحب واشمل واشكركم على حسن صالحكم
والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
اشكركم فخامه الرئيس الدكتور اسماعيل عمر
على كلمته والان ادعوا فخامه الرئيس رشاد
محمد العليمي رئيس المجلس القياده الرئاسي
اليمني للقاء كلمته فليتفضل
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
صاحب السمو الملكي الامير محمد بن سلمان
بن عبد العزيز ال سعود ولي العهد رئيس
مجلس الوزراء في المملكه العربيه السعوديه
الشقيقه فخامه الرئيس شيء رئيس جمهوريه
الصين الشعبيه الصديقه اصحاب الفخامه
معالي الامين العام لجامعه الدول العربيه
الاستاذ احمد ابو الغيث اصحاب المعالي
والسعاده السيدات والساده السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله وبركاته
اسمعوني في مستاهل كلمه هذه ان اتوجه
بالشكر للجزيل للمملكه العربيه السعوديه
واللي خادم الحرمين الشريفين جلاله الملك
سلمان بن عبد العزيز ال سعود على استضافه
هذا الحدث العام في تاريخ العلاقات
العربيه الصينيه وعلى المستوى الرفيع من
التنظيم وحسن الاستقبال وكرم الضيافه التي
هي خصال راسخه في مملكه الخير والمبادره
والعطاء كما نعرب عن خاله اعتزازنا
وتقديرنا لهذا البلد العظيم تحت القياده
الرشيده لخادم الحرمين الشريفين الملك
سلمان بن عبد العزيز وشعبه الكريم على
دوره الريادي ونهضته الفريده التي مثلت
قصه نجاح غير مسبوقه وبالهام من رؤيه 20
30 لصاحب السمو الملكي الامير محمد بن
سلمان بن عبد العزيز ولي العهد رئيس مجلس
الوزراء
كما توجهه بالشكر والتقدير لفخامه الرئيس
شيبه
رئيس جمهوريه الصين الشعبيه الصديقه التي
تربطها باليمن وشعبه علاقات تاريخيه متينه
تمتد لعقود طويله من الزمن وعلى جهوده
الحثيثه في نجاح هذه القمه لتكون محطه
انطلاق لتعزيز العلاقات العربيه الصينيه
واساسا متين لشراكه عربيه صينيه نحو
مستقبل مشرق قوامه المصالح المشتركه
والاحترام المتبادل وعدم التدخل في الشؤون
الداخليه للدول اصحاب الجلاله والفخامه
تمثل هذه القمه الاولى من نوعها فرصه
لتحقيق التقدم والازدهار والتنميه بشعوب
المنطقه العربيه والشعب الصينيه الصديق من
خلال صياغه استراتيجيه المشتركه للتعاون
ورواه موحده للسلام والتنميه المستدامه
واننا هنا نؤكد اعتزازنا الشديد بعمق
العلاقات التاريخيه العربيه الصينيه كما
نثمن ونحيي موقف الصين الثابت والمساند
للحكومه الشرعيه في بلادي وامن واستقرار
بلادي ايضا وسلامه اراضيه وفي المقابل
نجدد مواقفنا
الملتزما مبدا الصين الواحده
ولا شك انعقاد هذه القمه ياتي في ظروف
مثاليه لمقاربه تطلعات بلدان وشعوبنا في
عالم تعصف به النزاعات والحروب والفقر
والجوع والتشرد فضلا انت داعيات التغير
المناخي الحاد وما يتطلبه ذلك من جهود
المشتركه لتعزيز التضامن الجماعي وعدم ترك
الدول الاقل نموا غارقه في الصعاب بعيده
عن الركب لذلك يتعين علينا في هذه المرحله
الحاسبه الاستفاده القصوى من المبادلات
الاقليميه والدوليه الصالحه لما في ذلك
الحزام والطريق والشرق الاوسط الاخضر جنبا
الى جنب مع مضاعفه جهود صناعه السلام
والابداع والرياضه
لكن دعوني يكون واضحا معكم بالقول ان الذي
قدم في هذه المبادرات بحاجه اولا الى
النزاعات والحروب في المنطقه وفي المقدمه
دفع المليشيات الحوثيه الارهابيه مدعومه
من النظام الايراني الى الربوخ للاراده
الشعبيه والدوليه والحي الاولى دون
التدخلات الايرانيه الصافره في شؤون بلادي
وتزويد ميليشياتها بكافه انواع الاسلحه
المحرمه دوليه ومن جانبنا في مجلس القياده
الرئاسي والحكومه فاننا سنواصل العمل معكم
من اجل السلام الشامل الذي يستحقه شعبنا
اليمني وفقا للمرجعيات الثلاث المبادره
الخليجيه ومخرجات الحوار الوطني وقرارات
مجلس الامن ذات الصله وخصوص القرار اثنين
اثنين واحد سته الاخوان الحضور انما يواجه
اليمن في حلقه مهمه في ارث طريق الحرير
بمعابره البريه التاسعه ومنافذه وجزره
لاستراتيجيه وخليانه المتشاطيئه مع دول
المنطقه بين المضيق باب المندب وقناه
السويس سيكون اختبار هاما لتجمعنا هذا
وسيظلك ذلك تحديا للعالم يجمع لذلك فان
هذه القمه يجي ينبغي ان تمثل استجابه
واعيه واستشعارا واقعيا لهذه التحديات
المحدقه بامننا الجماعي
والتزاماتنا ومسؤولياتنا امام المجتمع
الدولي واننا نعمل ترجمه ذلك الى
استراتيجيه موحده لمواجهه التحدياتنا
المشتركه وفي المقدمه دعم شعبنا اليمني
ومسانده حكومته الوطنيه
واصلاحاتها الاقتصاديه والقدميه في مواجهه
المشروع المتطرف للمليشيات الحوثيه
الارهابيه
متخادمها مع تنظيم قائد القاعده وداعش
والعمل على انهاء الازمه الانسانيه
الاسواف العالم التي طال املها والتعاطي
السريع مع خطر الانسكااب النفطيه المحتمل
من الناقله صافر اسم البحر الاحمر قبل ان
يضعون التسويف وجميعا في قلب المواجهه مع
ازمات كبرى خارج السيطره
اصحاب الجلاله والفخامه السموم الاخوه
والصدور
يقول الصينيون القدامى ان الانسان عندما
يتوفر لهما يكفي من الحبوب يكونوا مؤدبا
كما انه يميز بين الكرامه والدله عندما
يؤمن له الاكل والملبس وخلال السنوات
الماضيه دمرت الحرب من دون اليمن واريافها
وستحقات سبل العيش وحولت البلاد الى بورت
نشطه لتصدير العنف وتغذيته بمجامع الفقراء
والجوعه في محاوله لتحويل بلادنا الى نقطه
انطلاق لتهديد امن المنطقه ونظرا
للاعتداءات المتكرره من جانبه للشيعه على
الشعب اليمني ودول المنطقه قرر مجلس
الدفاع الوطني تصنيفها منظمه الارهابيه
وهو الاجراء الذي يتطلب دعمكم الجماعي
كخيار سلمي لاحياء مسار العمل العمليه
السياسيه مع ضمان تدفق المساعدات
الانسانيه الى جميع المواطنين
وانني انتهيذ هذه المناسبه ليعرب شكري
لكافه الدول العربيه التي دعمت قرار
التصنيف من خلال جامعه الدول العربيه كما
نجدد موقفنا الثابت الى جانب الشعب
الفلسطيني لاقامه دولته المستقله في حدود
عام 1967
وعاصمتها القصه الشرقيه اصحاب الجلاله
والفخامه والسموم لا يزالوا تحالفنا مع
اشقائنا بقياده المملكه العربيه السعوديه
ودوله الامارات العربيه المتحده احدى اقوى
التحالفات التي عرفها العالم خلال العصر
الحديث حيث كانوا معنا على طول الطريق في
الدفاع عن دوله عضوين في الامم المتحده
ختاما ابارك لكم نجاح القيمتين السعوديه
الصينيه والخليجيه الصينيه واتمنى لقمه
هذه الرئاسه اخي خادم الحرمين الشريفين
الملك سلمان بن عبد العزيز نجاح ممثلا وان
تشكل مدخلا واطارا جامعا لتحقيق تطلعات
بينافي التنميه والسلام والاستقرار
والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
[تصفيق]
اشكركم فخامه الرئيس الدكتور رشاد محمد
العليمي على كلمته والان ادعوا فخامه
الفريق اول عبد الفتاح رئيس مجلس السياده
الانتقال السوداني كلمته
اعوذ بالله من الشيطان الرجيم بسم الله
الرحمن الرحيم صاحب السمو الملكي الامير
محمد بن سلمان ولي عهد ورئيس مجلس الوزراء
بالمملكه العربيه السعوديه الشقيقه فخامه
الرئيس
جمهوريه الصين الشعبيه صديقه اصحاب
الجلاله والفخامه
والسموم
مع السيد احمد ابو الغيط الامين العام
لجامعه الدول العربيه حضور جميعا سلام
عليكم ورحمه الله تعالى وبركاته
يطيب لي في هذا اليوم نتقدم بخارس الشكر
والتقدير لجلاله الملك سلمان بن عبد
العزيز ملك المملكه العربيه السعوديه
لدعوته لهذه القمه العربيه الصينيه الاولى
كما نشكر المملكه على حفاوه الاستقبال
وكرامه
في فخامه رئيس جمهوريه الصين الشعبيه
لحرصه
واهتمامه بالعلاقات العربيه الصينيه تتطلع
ان تكون هذه القمه خطوه متقدمه ومهمه
لتعزيز وتوطيد العلاقات التاريخيه بين
الجانبين العربي والصيني
عبر تفعيل كافه اليات التعاون في ست
المجالات
ان العلاقات
السودانيه الصينيه علاقات تاريخيه قديمه
استمثل الصين اكبر شريك للسودان في مختلف
المجالات الاقتصاديه
وتمثل تجربه ملتقى التعاون الزراعي
السوداني الصيني
نموذجا ندعو الى تطويره
ليسهم في تحقيق استراتيجيه الامن الغذائي
عربيا ودوليا لانه يفتح
افاقا واسعه
للتنسيق في مجالات التنميه والاستثمار
الزراعي
كما يتطلع السودان
لمزيد من التعاون العربي الصيني عبر
الشركات المنتجه في وقت احوج ما يكون فيه
العالم
للتعاون لتجاوز ازمه الغذاء والطاقه التي
تجتاح العالم اليوم
تنعقد هذه القمه توجد لفعاليات
الدور الثالث للمنتدى الصين العربي
الاصلاح والتنميه
والتي نامل ان ينتظر من عقادها بصوره
دوريه
مع مبادره التنميه العالميه التي طرحها
فخامه رئيس جمهوريه الصين الشعبيه
اللواء المتحده في سبتمبر 20 21
الداعيه الى التوافق العالمي والتكامل
الاستراتيجي لتحقيق المنافع المتبادله
اسال اصحاب الجلاله والفخامه والصمود
استراتيجيه الحزام والطريق التي طرحتها
القياده الصينيه
تمثل نموذجا
عمليا يجسده معاني التعاون
والترابط والتنميه على امتداد العالم
السودان جدعم هذا التوجه يسمى كذلك
المبادره التنمويه والاستثماريه التي
اعلنها صاحب السمو الملكي الامير محمد بن
سلمان بانشاء صندوق استثماري يشمل عدد من
دول العربيه ومن بينها السودان
فرضا عن المشروع التنموي القارئ الكبير
والمتمثل في مشروع خط السكه الحديد الذي
تم اعتماد فكرته في اجتماعات منظمه
التعاون الاسلامي الحادي عشر بالعاصمه
السنغاليه
السودانيه حتى مدينه دكار
بالسنغال غربا مثل هذا المشروع يمكن ان
يحدث اقتصاديه
وتنمويه غير مسبوقه خاصه اذا تكامل مع
مشروع الحزام والطريق يحقق معنا التواصل
وتبادل المنافع بين دول العالم
من التعاون
الصيني السوداني في مجال التنميه يعد
واحدا من نماذج النجاح المشترك
ويجسد معاني ومضامين الصداقه
ويتطلع السودان
لتطوير هذا التعاون من خلال مشروع
زراعي عربي صيني
الخطه الاستراتيجيه
للامن الغذائي العربي
مستفيدين من الخبرات
والامكانيات الصينيه المتنوعه
ويؤكد السودان
جاهزته لتحت كافه امكانياته التي تحقق هذه
الرؤيه الاستراتيجيه كما يؤكد السودان دعم
الاعمال الثمانيه المشتركه التي ستعمل
فيها الصين مع الجانب العربي في السنوات
المقبله
ختام حديثه اجنحه لي ان نجدد الشكر
والتقدير لجلاله خادم الحرمين الشريفين
وسمو ولي عهده على حسن ترتيبهم واستضافتهم
لهذه القمه التي سيكون لها مع بعضها كما
يمتد شكرنا وتقديرنا للقياده الصينيه
والاسره الجامعه العربيه والسلام عليكم
ورحمه الله وبركاته
[تصفيق]
اشكرك فخامه الفريق اول ركن عبد الفتاح
برهان على كلمته والان ادعوا فخامه الرئيس
الدكتور محمد يونس المنيفي رئيس جمهوريه
رئيس مجلس الرئاسي الليبي للقاء كلمته
فليتفضل
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
صاحب السمو الملكي الامير محمد بن سلمان
بن عبد العزيز ال سعود ولي عهد المملكه
العربيه السعوديه رئيس مجلس الوزراء
فخامه الرئيس
جمهوريه الصين الشعبيه اصحاب الجلاله
والفخامه والصمود معالي السيد احمد ابو
الغيط الامين العام لجامعه الدول العربيه
السيدات
يطيب لي في مستاهل كلماته ان اعرب عن جزيل
شكري وامتناني لخادم الحرمين الشريفين
الملك سلمان بن عبد العزيز ال سعود و
لصاحب السمو الملكي الامير محمد بن سلمان
بن عبد العزيز ولي عهد المملكه وللشعب
المملكه العربيه السعوديه لما لمستناه من
استقبال وحسن تنظيم والوفاده
ان التطورات الاقتصاديه والسياسيه
المتسارعه في عالمنا اليوم
تتطلب منا مرونه اكثر في تحديد مفهوم
الشركات الاقتصاديه
والابتعاد عن القوالب التقليديه جامده
التي حكمت العلاقات السياسيه والاقتصاديه
لبلداننا
منذ منتصف القرن الماضي خصوصا في ضوء
ماليه جمهوريه الصين الشعبيه من اهميه
لعلاقاتها بالعالم العربي وما نتجا عن هذا
التوجه من تطور في العلاقات العربيه
الصينيه منذ مؤتمر التعاون العربي الصيني
عام
2004 حيث اصبحت الدول العربيه الشركه
الاقتصاديه السابع للصين
من حيث حجم التبادل التجاري والمورد الاول
للنفط الخام للاقتصاد الصيني الذي حقق
قفزات واسعه منذ منتصف تسعينات القرن
الماضي واصبح مثالا يحتذى به ومحرك اساسيا
للاقتصاد العالمي
ايها السيدات والساده ان عقد هذه القمه في
مكانها
وزمانها المناسبين سيكون علامه فارقه
ومحطه تاريخيه عن طريق تعزيز العلاقات
الصينيه
ببلداننا العربيه هذه العلاقه التي بنيت
على اساس احترام سياده الدول والمصالح
المشتركه واحترام خيارات الشعوب وما زالت
هذه المبادي محل الالتزام واحترام من قبل
الجمهوريه الصينيه والبلدان العربيه
المنخرطه في هذه الشركه منذ انطلاقيها
اصحاب الجلاله والفخامه والصمود ان بلدي
ليبيا من البلدان التي ربطتها على قاف
ثابته بجمهوريه الصين الشعبيه تاسست على
موقف الصين الداعم الاستقلال الدوله
الليبيه عام 1951 والتزام ليبيا بمبدا
الصيني الواحد وكذلك على علاقه اقتصاديه
مميزه نمت بمعدل سنوي فوق 17% في الفتره
من 1995 حتى 20 20 تاسيسا على ذلك فاننا
نطمح الى ان تلعب الصين الدوري الذي يناسب
ثقل الدولي ويناسب اهميه العلاقه بين
البلدين من اجل استقرار ليبيا وضمان
استقلالها واحتراضيها الامر الذي سيؤدي
الى ما نطمح اليه دوران عجله التنميه
وعوده الشركات الصينيه الى العمل في
مشاريع البنيه التحتيه والتطور العمراني
التي انطلقت عام 2010 وتوقفت بسبب التغير
السياسي وحاله عدم الاستقرار التي مازال
استشه البلاد
ان دوله ليبيا
احتفلت منذ ايام بالقضاء على الارهاب
وجماعات المتطرفه وتمكنت من تحقيق الامن
والاستقرار والعكاس وانعكس ذلك ايجابيا
على استئناف انتاج النفط والغاز بطاقته
الطبيعيه
وهذا الذي شجع العديد من الشركات الاجنبيه
من مزاوله نشاطها في هذا القطاع ومن هذا
الصدد ندعم ونشجع العمل المشترك للقضاء
على بار الارهاب والتطرف اينما وجد وهو ما
استطاعت بلادي تحقيقه من خلال تلاحم كل
الليبيه للقضاء على هذه الظاهره ختاما ان
بلد ليبيا سوف تحتفل بعد ايام قبائل بعيد
استقلال الحاج و70 في اجواء يملؤها الترقب
والامل في ان تنجح جهودنا في المصالحه
وبناء الثقه من ازمه وبناء الثقه بين
الاطراف السياسيه ومكونات الشعب الليبي من
اجل الخروج بالبلاد من ازمتها السياسيه
وانهاء المراحل الانتقاليه وانتقال سلمي
للسلطه من خلال الانتخابات الرئاسيه
ونيابيه نزيهه وشفافه يقبل بنتائجها ابناء
الشعب اللي في كافه وانا في هذا الصدد
نتوقع اعلى درجات الموازره والدعم لجهود
المجلس السياسي من قبل الاشقاء العرب
وجمهوريه الصين الشعبيه لتحقيقه هذا الهدف
في اقرب اجل ممكن تقبله شكري وامتلاني
والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
[تصفيق]
اشكرك فخامه الرئيس الدكتور
عزيز اخنوش رئيس الحكومه في المملكه
المغربيه للقاء كلمته يتفضل
اصحاب الجلاله اصحاب السمو اصحاب المعالي
والفخامه ايها الحضور الكريم
شغفانيه صاحب جلاله الملك محمد السادس
نصره الله
بتمثيل جلالته في اشغال هذه القمه العربيه
الصينيه الاولى
هذا الخطاب نيابه عن جلالتهم
صاحب السمو الملكي الامير محمد بن سلمان
بن عبد العزيز ال سعود
ولي العهد رئيس مجلس الوزراء واخي العزيز
صاحب الفخامه السيد
شيجين بينك رئيس جمهوريه الصين الشعبيه
وصديقي الكبير حضرت السيدات والساده اودو
في البدايه ان اتوجهها بالشكر الجديد
الى اخي الاعز خادم الحرمين الشريفين
الملك سلمان بن عبد العزيز ال سعود حفظه
الله ومن خلاله الى اخي العزيز ولي العهد
صاحب السمو الملكي الامير محمد بن سلمان
والى الشعب السعودي الشقيق على استضافته
هذه القمه العربيه الصينيه الاولى وعلى ما
بدلته السلطات السعوديه من جهود لتجهيء
الظروف الملائمه لتنظيمها وانجاحهم
والشكومه وصول ايضا
لفخامه السيد جين بينج رئيس جمهوريه الصين
الشعبيه على رئاسه المشتركه لهذه القمه
كما اعرب لمعالي السيد احمد ابو الغيث
الامين العام لجماعه الدول العربيه عن
تقديري للعمل القيم التي قامت به الجامعه
من اجل التحضير الجيد لاجل لاعمال هذه
القمه
ويطيب لنا بهذه المناسبه ان نجدد تهاننا
للشعب الصيني الصديق على نجاح المؤتمر 20
للحزب الشيوعي الصيني كما نجدد التعبير
لصديقنا الكبير فخامه الرئيس عن اسماء
عبارات التهاني على تجديد انتخابه على راس
الحزب للمره الثالثه مما يؤكد الثقه
المتواصله التي يحظى بها هذا الشعب الصيني
الصديق وقيادته الحزب الشيوعي الصيني وهي
مناسبه كذلك للاشاده ب نطق على المؤتمر
بخصوص العلاقات مع العالم العربي
اصحاب جلاله والفخامه والسمول معالي حضرات
سيده والساده نعيش اليوم لحظه قويه في
مسار التعاون العربي الصيني لتشكل القمه
العربيه الصينيه الاولى حدث تاريخيا
ومنعفه مهما في العلاقات بين الجانبين وهي
ايضا فرصه سائحه لاضافه لبنه جديده الى
ساحل العلاقات التقليديه القويه القائمه
بين العالم العربي والصيني فهذه القمه
بقدر ما هي مناسبه لاستشراف الافاق
المستقبليه لشراكه المتميزه فاننا نحوس
على ان تحتل مكان في خريطه علاقات منطقه
العربيه مع مختلف شركائها من دولين
وتجمعات ومنظمات اقليه اقليميه وقويه فهي
تشترك ذلك موعد الاستحضار الابعاد
الحضاريه وغوابت التاريخيه التي استندت
على شبكه
علاقات الانسانيه وتمازج ثقافي متمر
والتاثير الايجابي متبادل في ايطار طريق
الحرير القديم هذه العلاقه العريقه التي
نسجت من خلال هذا التلاحم وهذا التلاقم
عفوا هذا التلقم الثقافي والحضاري الذي
امتد عبر الزمن وغطاء وغابه الماضي
بالحاضر تستشرف المستقبل اليوم في تعاون
متجدد ومستمر لعل ابرز تجليته والتعاون
العربي الصيني القائم في اطار مبادره
الحزام والطريق
ان هذه القمه العقيد في السياق دولي مش
حلم الازمات التي خلفتها اثار جائعه كونا
والتطور الجيش
الجيوستراتيجيه الدقيقه التي يشودها
العالم وما صاحبها من اضطرابات وبؤه
التوتر ونزاعت مسلحه لها اتى مباشر على
منطقتنا العربيه وعلى شريكنا الصين وعلى
دول العالم وهو ما يعطي للشقق
الاستراتيجيه
بيننا اهم اهميه خاصه ومن منطلق انها
تتوخى تجاوز اعطاها التحديات متعدده
الاوجه ولعل التعاون بين الصين والدول
العربيه خلال فتره الجائحه على كافه
المستويات الصحيه والتي تقع في بعض
الاحيان كما هو الشان بالنسبه للمملكه
المغربيه الى مستوى شراكه مؤسسه وعلميه
وصناعيه لاسيه ما في مجال التلقيحات اصحاب
الجلاله والفخامه والسمومه والمعالي حضرات
السيدات والساده
اننا نسجل باعتزاز حفظ جمهوريه الصين
الشعبيه السابقه على دعم الامن والاستقرار
بالمنطقه العربيه
ومساندتها لتجاوز الازوات الازمات التي
تشهدها والحج من تداعيتها وذلك بما هو
مشهود به لديبلوماسيه الصينيه من حكمه
وغزانه تسهم في التقريب بين وجهات النظر
وتغليف فضائل الحوار لتجاوز واقع الاضطراب
وعدم الاستقرار وهنا نود ان نشير الا انه
مات وجود هو المنطقه العربيه من تحديات
تهدد امنا او اصدقائها
في بعض الحالات مع الاسف الى سياسات
وسلوكيات بعد الدول العربيه
التجاهل بعض الاخر ومن هنا وجبت شديد على
انه لا يمكن تجاوز هذه الوضع المليء
بالمخاطر دون الالتزام بمبادئ حسن الجوار
واحترام كاد الوطنيه للدول ووحده الترابيه
والامتناع عن التدخل في شؤونها الداخليه
ومن جهه اخرى يعتبر دعم الصين راسخ للقضيه
الفلسطينيه
العادله مكسبا دوليا تمينا من اجل حل عادي
الودائم لهذه القضيه في اطار روايات
الصعيد الصله وفي مقدمتها تلك المتعلقه
بالقدس الشريف وفي هذا الايطالي وبالصفه
رئيسا للجنه القدس لا يسعون الا ان نتمنى
عاليا دعم الصين الثابت للحفاظ على الوضع
القانوني
والتاريخي للمدينه المقدسه ورفضها لاتحاد
اي قرارات احاديه الجانب من شانها ان
تقوده جهود احياء عمليه السلام وابعاد ملف
القدس عن طويله المفاوذات وعزله عن ملفاته
الوضعي النهائي وهو ما سيزيد من ت
والاوضاع والتعقيدها في الوقت الذي نسعى
فيه مع كل كل القوى المحبه للسلام لتوفير
الضيوف الملائمه لتغليب خيار السلام وعوده
الطرفين الفلسطيني والاسرائيلي لطاوله
مفاوضات اصحاب الجلاله والفخامه والسمول
معالي حضرات السيدات والساده تعرف
العلاقات العربيه الصينيه تنوعا وتطوعا
على السعيد السياسي والاقتصادي والتجاري
والثقافي والانساني بفضل
الله
بشكل الامثل للمساهمه في تحقيق ما يصبو له
العالم العربي من نهضه الاقتصاديه حقيقه
حقيقيه
وتطور علمي وتكنولوجي لا سيما خلال اطلاق
مشاريع
دعم البنيه التحتيه واللوجستيكيه والتنميه
البشريه ونقل التكنولوجيات ولكن بالرغم من
ان الصيني الشريك الاقتصادي الاول الدول
العربيه
لان الا ان التبادل تجاري بين الجانبين
وان سجل مستوايات جيدا من حيث الحجم
والتنوع والكثافه حيث تناهز 240 مليار ولا
سنه 2020 فهو لم يرقق بعد الى المستوى
المؤهلات المتاحه كما انه يعرف عجزا كبيرا
في الصادرات العربيه نحو الصين باستثناء
الصادرات من النفط والغاز مما يستدعي
العمل المشترك من اجل تشجيع هذا الصادرات
وتنويعها لتكون قاطره للنهوض بالاقتصاد
العربي الصناعي والفلاحي والخدمات كما ان
عدد السياح الصيني الذين يظنون الدول
العربيه اقل من عدد نبضائهم العرب الذين
يتوجهون الى جمهوريه السابقه وهنا ندعو
للعمل على رفع عدد السياح في الاتجاهين
لتحقيق ما نصبه اليه جميعا من مزيد من
التقاوي والتواصل اصحاب الجلاله والفخامه
شمول معالي حضرات سيده والساده ان بين من
بين وكائز السياسه الخارجيه للمملكه
المغربيه تطوير التعاون جنوب جنوب وتنويع
الشركاء والانفتاح على المجموعات
الاقليميه حيث تربط المملكه بعدد كبير
منها علاقات صداقه وتضامن والتعاون مثنيه
وبالخصوص تلك المنتميه لدول الجنوب وفي
هذا الصدد نريد
تعبير عن السياحين العميق لما يتبعوا
العلاقه المغربيه الصينيه من صداقه
تاريخيه متينه وتعاون مدمر في مختلف
المجالات ومن تنسيق والتشاور
بخصوص مختلف القضايا ذاتي الاهتمام
المجتمعك وفي هذه السياق مؤكده على انقراض
المملكه المغربيه في سياتي في سياسه الصين
الواحده كاساس للعلاقات بين البلدين
الصديقين كما ان دعمنا للمبادرات لقدمتها
الصين كمجموعه اصدقاء
الدنيا يعكس مستوى التعاون الوثيق بين
البلدين الصديقين كما يحرص المغرب على
المضيق قدما في ترسيخ الشواكه
الاستراتيجيه المبرمه بين البلدين في ماي
2016 ومذكره تفاهم حول مبادره الحزام
والتاريخ وبالتالي توسيع افاق التعاون
الثنائي ليشمل قطاعه جديده واعده وذات
قيمه مضافه
المملكه المغربيه اليوم تاكيد استعدادها
للاسهال فعال في رفع من مستواه هذه
الشواكه الاستراتيجيه في جميع المجالات في
التزام دائم بالقضايا العربيه العادله
والمشروعه من اجل بناء نظام سياسي
واقتصادي عالمي اكثر عدل وتوازن في احترام
تام لسياده الدول ووحدتها الترابيه وعدم
تدخل في شؤونها الداخليه وفضل الاطار فان
المملكه المغربيه تشيد بالمباره العربيه
الصينيه التي سيتم تبنيها في اطار هذه
القمه وتؤكد استعدادها للانسان بكل جديه
وتفاعليه فيما يتضمن سيتضمنه اعلان الرياض
من توصيات
بالشواكه الاستراتيجيه العربيه الصينيه
ووضع خصوص قويه لبناء المستقبل
واقع الانسان العربي والانخراط في مجتمعي
المعرفه والاتصال ولا يفتن بهذه المناسبه
ان اجدد الاعراب عن فائق اعتزازي بعمق
الروابط القائمه بين المملكه العربيه
السعوديه
والمملكه المغربيه وبتانه علاقتهم
الثنائيه مشيدا بما يجمع البلدين الشقيقين
من شواك نموذجيه قوامها التشاور بالناء
والتضامن فعال والتعاون المثمر في مختلف
المجالات الاستراتيجيه كما اعرضوا عن
اعتزازه بما يضبط الاسرتين من اواس اواصر
الاخوه الصادقه والتقدير المتبادل وما
يتقاصر والشعبان الشقيقان من موده
والصداقه وفي الختام اود ان اجدد شكر
الخالص للمملكه العربيه السعوديه قياده
وحكومه وشعبان على حسن الاستقبال على ما
بدلته من جهود لتنظيم والانجاح القمه لتح
منصبه اليه جميعا من ترسيخ اسس شراكه
حقيقيات تخدم السلام والاستقرار وتنتج
التقدم واخاء المشترك والسلام عليكم ورحمه
الله تعالى وبركاته
[تصفيق]
اشكر معالي السيد عزيز اخنوش على كلمته
والان ادعو دوله السيده نجيب ميقاتي رئيس
مجلس وزراء في جمهوريه اللبنانيه لالقاء
كلمته فليتفضل شكرا
صاحب السمو الملكي الامير محمد بن سلمان
بن عبد العزيز ولي عهد رئيس وزراء المملكه
العربيه السعوديه فخامه الرئيس جمهوريه
الصين الشعبيه
اصحاب الجلاله والفخامه والسمو والمعالي
السيد احمد ابو الغيث اصحاب السعاده
ودوا في البدايه انا اتقدم تحيات اتقدم
بتحيه خاصه لخادم الحرمين الشريفين الملك
سلمان بن عبد العزيز ال سعود امد الله
بعمره
وتوجه بجزيل الشكر للمملكه العربيه
السعوديه الشقيقه وقيادتها الحكيمه لكرامه
الاستضافه والاقامه وللامانه العامه
للتجمع العربيه على حسب التحضير للحدث
العالمي الذي نعيشه اليوم
يستحضرني في خلال هذه اللقاء قول لسمو
الامير محمد بن سلمان بن عبد العزيز حفظه
الله
عندما قال عندما سبق وقال طموحنا لا حدود
له
طموحنا ان يكون اقتصادنا اكبر مما نحن فيه
والان اليوم في كلمه الاستفتاح قال فخامه
الرئيس شيجن بنك ان القضايا العظيمه تبدا
بالحلم وتنجز بالعمل الملموس
بهذا ليس غريبا ان يكون ان تكون عيون
العالم شخصيه اليوم لمتابعه اجتماعنا لما
له من دلالات ومعاني ان عالمنا العربي
الذي يملك الكثير من المؤهلات البشريه
والطبيعيه هو في صلب اهتمام العالم واولهم
جمهوريه الصين الشعبيه التي تربطنا بها
اواصر صداقه وقواسم مشتركه
وها هي هذه العلاقات بين العالمين بين
العالمين ترتقي اليوم الى مستوى غير مسبوق
يفتح وليس فقط بعالمنا العربي والصيني بل
ايضا للعالم اجمع افاق من العمل المشترك
القائم على التعاون المجدي للطرفين
والاستفاده المشتركه من التجارب الناجحه
ايها الساده يتطلع لبنان الى هذه القمه
بكل امل ويعمل بجهد تفعيل التعاون بينه
وبين اشقائه العرب وبينه وبين الصين وهي
ثاني اقوى اقتصادا بالعالم ومركز الثقل
للاستقرار وللتنميه والتطور العلمي
اكرر شكري وامتناني للدوله المضيفه ونتمنى
لاعمال هذه القمه النجاه ولنا كل الامان
بتفعيل التعاون فيما بيننا لما فيه مصلحه
شعوبنا وبلدان العالم اجمعه السلام عليكم
والله ولي التوفيق
[تصفيق]
اشكر دول السيد نجيب ميقاتي على كلمته
والان ادعو دوله السيد محمد شايع السوداني
رئيس مجلس وزراء في جمهوريه العراق للقاء
كلمته فليتفضل شكرا جزيلا بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم
الاخ العزيز صاحب السمو الملكي محمد بن
سلمان ولي العهد ورئيس مجلس الوزراء في
المملكه العربيه السعوديه الشقيقه فخامه
الرئيس شيجين بين رئيس الجمهوريه الصين
الشعبيه الصديق اصحاب الجلاله والفخامه
والسموك مع الامين العام للجامعه العربيه
السيدات والساده السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
وبركاته
بدل اسمحوا لي ان اتقدم بالشكر الجزيل
لخادم الحرمين الشريفين الملك سلمان بن
عبد العزيز ولي العهد على حسن الاستقبال
وكرم الضيافه واود ان اثني على اهميه عقد
مثل هذه القمه التي تاتي ضمن فهم عميق
للساحه الدوليه لنتمكن من تبني سياسه
خارجيه متوازنه وتكامليه تقدم مصالح
شعوبنا ودودنا وامتنا وتعزز الاستقرار
والامن والازدهار لقد اثبتت السنوات
القليله الماضيه والتحديات التي مرت على
شعوبنا على صعوبه الاقتصاديه والصحيه
والسياسيه ان الشراكه المسئوله بين الشعوب
والدول والتعاون البينيه والنوايا الطيبه
تمهدوا لحلول واقعيه لمشاكل قديمه
من هذا المنطلق فان العراق يدعم جميعا
جهود اكراميه لتعزيز علاقات التعاون
والصداقه المرتده بين الدول العربيه
والصين اذ نرى في هذه القمه فرصه للتكامل
الاقتصادي في منطقتنا من خلال تعزيز
التعاون مع الصين والافاده من الخبرات
الصينيه في شتى المجالات
دون ان ننسى تجارب مكافحه الفقر والاوبئه
وتطوير الزراعه وجهود مكافحه التصحر
وغيرها
على الصعيد الثنائي فان العراق يرتبط مع
الصين بعلاقات عريق اخذت حيزا متلامسا من
الاهتمام وتطور خلال السنوات الماضيه على
الصعيدين الحكومي والشعبي وحظيت بروابط
وثيقه قائمه على اساس الصداقه والمصالح
المشتركه والتعاون الاقتصادي والتبادل
التجاري ويتطلع العراق الى تعزيز الشراكه
ضمن مبادره الحزام والطريق وظن مجالات
الاستثمار والطاقه ومشاريع البنا التحتيه
اصحاب الجلاله والفخامه والسمو مر العراق
على مدى نصف القرن بظروف القاهره دفعته
الى الانشغال وابعدته عن دوره التاريخي
ومهامه لكننا عازمنا على استعاده عافيته
ومكانته ودوره ولم يرضى عن ذلك بدلا
ان خطواتنا في المرحله القادمه ستركز على
جمله مساحات اولا تطوير الاقتصاد والتوفير
الخدمات وادعوكم اليوم للانفتاح الاقتصادي
على العراق فهو يمثل بيئه واحده للاستثمار
ويمتلك مقومات نجاح مهمه بشريه وماديا
واننا نهتم بالتكامل والترابط مع اصدقائنا
في المنطقه على صعيد البنى التحتيه لنقدم
افضل الخدمات لشعوبنا ثانيا عدم السماح
لان يكون العراق مقررا او ممر للاعتداء
على دول
ونرفض في ذات الوقت الاعتداء على اراضينا
وعلى الجميع احترام سياده العراق
وهنا لابد من التفكير بما تعرضت له بلادنا
من هجمه ارهابيه وحشيه هددت العالم باسره
لكن العراقيين وقفوا دفاعا عن النفس
والمنطقه والعالم وقدمت قواتنا المسلحه
بصنفها كافه تضحيات كبيره ودماء عزيزه
وتحقق النصر باذن الله فاليوم نشكر كل من
وقف معنا في محنتنا ونعرف ان دول المنطقه
والعالم لن تنسى معركتنا المشاركه تلك
وستقف معنا في نهرتنا عرفانا ووفاء
ثالثا ان منطقه ما هي قلب العالم وحلقه
الوصل بين قارات اسيا وافريقيا واوروبا
وتحتل منطقه مكانه استراتيجيه مميزه في
مجال الطاقه والعراق قلب هذه المنطقه
تاريخيه وثقافيه ومن بين اهم الدول
المصدره للنفط في العالم لذلك فاننا نؤكد
حصنا على استقرار النظام الاقتصادي العالم
من خلال دورنا كعوب مؤسس في منظمه اوبك
ونستهدف معاشركائنا تحقيق الاستقرار في
انتاج النفط واسعاره بما يحقق المصالح
المتوازنه للمتجين والمستهلكين على حد
سواء ويشجع التنميه المستدامه اقتصاديا
وبهيا
رابعا يعتز العراق بهويته العربيه
والاسلاميه ولا يفوتنا هنا ان ناكد اولا
على التزام العراقي الثابت والمبدئي
ووقوفه الى جانب الشعب الفلسطيني ودفاعه
عن حقه في دولته الوطنيه وعاصمتها القدس
اصحاب الجلاله والفخامه والسمو العراق احد
اهم ركائز منطقه منذ الاف السنين واهم
جسور ادامه الوصل فيها ومن العراق العريق
نمد يد الاخوه الى اشقائنا وجيراننا
واصدقائنا ونعتز بعلاقاتنا المنفتحه مع
دول الغرب والشرق على اساس المصالح
المشترك
خامسه نحن متفائلون بمستقبلين المشرق
المشترك المشرف وفخرون بارثنا ومنطقتنا
فاليوم تعقد هذه القمه المهمه ونرحب
بالصين الصديقه وفخامه رئيسها هنا في
الرياض
واستضافت بغداد قبل ايام منتدى الحضارات
العريقه الذي ضم 10 دول من اربع قارات
وتستضيف قطر الشقيقه حاليا نهائيات كاس
العالم لكره القدم بنجاح باهر وقبل ذلك
استضافت مدينه شرم الشيخ في مصر الشقيقه
مؤتمر المناخي 2022 كل ذلك يؤكد ان
منطقتنا تمثل ثقلا متزايد في عالم متغير
ولابد لنا معا من صياغه مستقبلنا فيه بما
يحقق انفتاح هنا الايجابي على جميع
الاصدقاء من ناحيه واسرارنا على فرض
احترامنا وخصوصياتنا من ناحيه اخرى
والعراق راغب وكفيل وملزم بان لا يتدخل
جهدا للتعاون نحو صياغه نظام اقليمي يؤسس
للاستقرار ويمهده للازدهار والتكامل وعازم
على بذل قصار جهده لفتح باب البناء ويشدد
على ضروره تبني الحوار المباشر والنوايا
الحسنه ونبذ العنف كسبيل لزع فتيل التوتر
ويكون حجر الاساسي في انهاء ذلك الانطباع
بان منطقتنا منطقه ازمات لتكون منطقه
تكامل وتفاهم تتبادل فيها شعوبنا الموارد
والمعرفه والخبره والتكنولوجيا وكل ذلك من
اجل مستقبل عنوانه السلام والتعاون
والرفاه والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
السيد محمد شايع السوداني على كلمته امام
اصحاب الجلاله والفخامه وسموب وثائق
التاليه بعد التوافق عليها مشروع اعلان
الرياضه وثيقه الخطوط العريضه لخطه
التعاون الشامل بعد جمهوريه الصين الشعبيه
والدول العربيه ووثيقه تعميق الشراكه
الاستراتيجيه العربيه الصينيه من اجل
السلام والتنميه التي تم التوافق عليها من
جميع الدول والان ادعوا فخامه الريشي
يجيبهم رئيس جمهوريه الصين الشعبيه للقاء
كلمته القدامي
فنجان
تورته
[موسيقى]
بنك بنك
السلم والامان في المنطقه
الى التواصل والاستفاده المتبادله بين
الحضارات متعزيز تعيش المتناقم بين
الحضارات المختلفه
بالانجازات التي تتحققت الدول العربيه
شهدت العلاقات
حيث اقام الجانبين ان العلاقات شركه
استراتيجيه القائمه على تعاون شامل
والتنميه المشتركه لمستقبل افضل
كما قام بالصين الشامله
او على قاده شركه الاستراتيجيه مع اثنا
عشر دوله عربيه
واعرابات 17 دوله عربيه عن دعمها للمبادره
التنميه العالميه
وانضمت 15 دوله عربيه الى البنك الاسياوي
للاستثمار فلبوميه تحتيه
[موسيقى]
وتم انشاء 17 سنه
قد تكللت القمه الثانيه العربيه
بالنجاحتان
حيث اتفق الجانبان على
العمل
بكل الجهود على البناء
المجتمع الصيني
[موسيقى]
العربيات الصين العربيه
الى المستقبل
تقدم البشري شكرا لكم
[تصفيق]
على التقدم والنهضه مره اخرى وسوف نثبت
ذلك كل يوم يعني ختام القمه وارفع الجلسه
شكرا
[تصفيق]